Yeah,
yeah.
Two,
one.
Kevin Lee.
What's up man?
What's going on island?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know a guy get you some thanks for even for doing it.
I,
before the fight happened,
I had kind of already had,
in my mind,
I'm like,
okay,
it's been a year since we last kind of did this.
And it was right after the bar bowls a fight.
And I was like,
okay,
I'm a,
I'm gonna get through the fight and then I'm gonna do this.
The result wasn't exactly what I want,
you know what I mean?
And it made me hesitant about doing it,
but I was like,
ah,
this is the story,
you know what I mean?
And this is,
as I said,
kind of like was upset at myself for a few days.
Eventually I just Kinda got over and I'm like,
you know what?
I said I was going to do it before.
I'm not about to be no sore as loser.
And
yeah,
might as well.
Like I said,
I love you whether you win or lose,
I'm just,
you know,
it's,
it's a giant part of the game.
Half the game is losing.
Someone has to win someone else to lose.
If you watch a fight,
someone's losing.
Yes,
it's a draw.
And I figure it's,
it's all about how you approach it,
how you take it into the next fight.
And really when you look at it,
I mean it sucks.
It really does and I hate it.
And like any,
like it's something that ball's up Masada me like I go over,
I replayed a fight a million times in my head and I actually hate losing and I
hate that feeling but it's just the reality and it's like it's just real life
and just realized nothing.
You can do it.
There's nothing you do once it's over you.
The only thing you can do is learn and grow.
Exactly.
And the guy you fought as a stud man you thought fought Hofeld dos Anjos,
he's a fucking legitimate world champion fighter.
Yeah.
When,
when I was approached with the fight and in kind of start really diving into it
and really looking at him like I always like a really big challenge.
And that one was definitely one,
you know,
he had already had a lot of fights.
Uh,
that went five rounds.
He had fucked,
he's fought pretty much everybody,
you know,
uh,
Camaros.
Uzman was his last fight,
a Colby,
Covington,
EFL could be p I've already fought like a lot of,
uh,
top top guys and for five rounds.
So I knew what type of challenge it was.
It's just I hope myself at a high esteem.
So I was like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm just ready to do it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
The,
the fight itself was,
was good,
but either way I'm gonna learn from it and,
and,
and grow from an end.
I still got a whole long,
long road ahead of me.
So
you do have a long road ahead of you,
but you know,
as we were talking about that long run could sneak up on you real quick.
And before you know it,
you know,
you're 37 years old trying to figure out if you still want to fight.
Yeah.
That's,
that's how it happens to guys.
I've seen it happen to guys.
Yeah.
So I feel like if you approach a smart,
you know what I mean,
you can still get done,
which is what I'm trying to do.
Right.
Uh,
I kinda already knew that I needed to make some changes and do some things
different.
Um,
even before this fight and before my last one too.
but you know,
I just was like,
okay,
I'm gonna just get through this one and then I'll do it and now I'm gonna get
through this one and then I'll do it.
But you know,
that's kind of a big wake up call to just like,
all right,
it's time to get outside of the comfort zone in,
in any kind of,
do something different and,
and kind of do what I already know I've got to do.
What did you think was going to happen in the fight and what was surprising?
I didn't think they will be able to keep the pace for sure.
Um,
but what surprised me was how smart he was in,
in how,
uh,
he beat me tactically more than anything is,
you know,
when I was going,
he wasn't doing,
you know,
and he kind of,
he controlled the pace better than I thought he was going to.
You know,
I thought once I set that pace that he was gonna be right there with me.
But then as it got going,
I started to realize,
oh,
he's not really expending much energy.
He's Kinda just letting me burn out my energy.
And,
and,
and then he took his moment when,
when I made the last mistake.
And really when it boiled down to it,
I lost one position at the end there,
uh,
where I went for a take down and,
you know,
nine times out of 10 when I go and club back,
the guy hits his knees.
Uh,
but he,
he just stayed on his feet.
I stepped out and when I hit my knees,
it's like lost that position and it against a guy like that.
So dangerous of black belt.
And is a,
is so good.
I knew one slip up was going to be all the need and not think he knew that too.
And he was just kind of waiting,
biding his time and hoping that I slip up.
It seemed like you expended a lot of energy early on.
It seemed like by the time he got the submission you were fairly tired.
Yeah.
I mean,
follow,
she always used to tell me to send it.
It was always a,
there's tired and can and tired and can't,
you know,
it's a fight.
It's,
you're gonna be tired.
Uh,
but I,
I still do think I have my legs underneath me and,
and still could,
it's just,
I could have played it better tactically.
I could have had had,
you know,
more time when I wasn't just going,
going as,
like you said,
especially in that first round,
if I would have had a little bit better experience maybe or,
or something,
I,
you know,
I don't know,
I'll figure that out,
but,
uh,
I could have played it a little smarter like he did.
Are you,
do you have a person that's giving you strategy or are you sort of making your
strategy up on the fly?
That's one of the things that,
that's kind of the main thing that,
that um,
uh,
I,
Robert Falls was that guy for me until he passed and,
and then I kind of just picked up the ball and,
you know,
I understand fighting.
Um,
but yeah,
it's mostly me doing the strategy and right now that that's where I'm in the
limbo of,
of trying to find somebody who already has that experience and has already been
there and done it,
uh,
to tell me a little better strategy.
Yeah.
I think it's so critical,
man.
I really do.
And we had this conversation over the phone about it.
I think that,
uh,
a young fighter with a lot of potential like yourself,
like this is a reason why fighters of trainers,
there's a reason why fighters have head coaches.
It's re it's not because they want to give up all their money.
It's because it helps.
And you can delegate those,
that,
that thought process to a master.
Someone who's a master of martial arts who understands positions or understand
strategies,
seen guys tire.
It's seen guys good seeing you in the gym,
senior grind,
understands your skillset,
understands how you are when you come in,
perfect.
Understands how you are when you come in tired,
you know,
so that,
that is just giant Ha.
It having someone who understands you psychologically as well.
And it also having someone that you respect and that you want to impress.
All those things are huge.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a big one.
Especially like you said,
being able to talk to you too in,
in,
in being able to understand you.
I think that's what rob did really well,
uh,
and any kind of was so good.
He kind of like reel me in a little bit.
Like I'm the type,
I'm just kind of go,
go,
go.
And I kind of think higher to myself and then maybe even I am,
but that's just high,
you know?
So that's how you have confidence.
Yeah.
So,
but he was the type to kind of reel me in and he used to even tell me like,
hey,
you don't gotta get hit so much or you know,
I'll,
I'll stand in front of a guy.
And just like,
especially when I was younger,
it was a little even worse and you know,
cause that's just how I be feeling.
But you know,
he was the Connor to type to,
to reel me in more than anything.
It's not like he would tell me one specific techniques or,
or it was even about his style or anything like that.
It was just the way that he was able to kind of get through to me and kind of
make me understand what it is that I'm trying to do.
Yeah.
And you guys,
you guys have just a good relationship too.
He was such a good guy,
man.
Yeah.
Such a good dude to,
I mean,
just,
just losing him.
I mean,
it was devastating for the whole mixed martial arts world,
but losing him for you had to be a real,
just a giant change in your career.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
which fight?
What did he die before
he died right after the Tony fight,
which is a whole nother piece of it.
You know,
I,
I know he had a whole lot of,
uh,
things going on early in his life,
especially,
you know,
with his family.
And,
um,
when we went to his memorial and people were kind of explaining,
you know what,
it's like growing up in a,
a,
uh,
he grew up a Jehovah witness.
So he's like explaining what it's like to grow up like that and you know,
to try and get away from that and having your family disown you and how like
that can I,
I understand.
I understand the importance of family,
so I can get that.
But then even I'm like,
man,
you know,
they would tell us he,
we were more so keeping them alive longer than,
than anything.
So I'm like,
man,
if I would've won that fight with Tony,
it's like,
fuck what he shows what he's still be here.
You know what I mean?
Those are the type of like,
I'm like,
did I do it to myself?
Almost,
but I already know,
I'm already at the point where I kinda got over it a little bit and I kind of
understand that I'm not going to be able to replace them by any means.
Uh,
but I am going to have to get that person who can still speak to me in that same
light.
You know,
the only way that I'm gonna make it right is to win that title in and it for
him,
you know,
he kind of saw that from me and he was a counter to one that gave me that
confidence to say,
cause he,
he's already coached multiple UFC champions.
So when he told me that,
that he could see me being a champ,
that really,
like,
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Like I didn't really,
like,
I kind of got it a little bit,
but I didn't really know it until like he gave me that kind of confidence.
Um,
so the only thing that's gonna make it right is to go out there and win a title.
And that's,
that's if I got,
it wouldn't,
no matter what I gotta do,
I'm not stopping until I do it.
So are you 100% committed to one 70 now?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think it's,
I think it's right.
You look like you're about one 90 now,
right?
Yeah.
I'm just about,
I'm about one 85,
one 86.
Um,
which is normally what I would be about getting ready for a 55 pound fight to,
um,
actually when I stepped into the cage,
I was lighter,
uh,
going into this fight than it was for some of my,
my 55 pounds fights.
Um,
yeah,
I walked in about one 81.
Um,
and like for the 25 was one 84.
So,
you know,
that 25 was a mess because of the staff,
right?
Like,
yeah,
that's,
you guys have a decision where you had to make,
whether you're not,
you're going to pull out of the fight.
Yeah.
I mean,
I tried my best to keep it from everybody.
So in our kind of succeeded in it.
Um,
I mean really the only one,
something over it at the weigh ins,
right?
Yeah.
Put a makeup by the Suzy,
the girl.
She,
uh,
she did it for me,
but you know,
that really just made the,
the,
the weight cut and then my body much worse.
I mean,
I don't really look at the fight in say that Tony's a dog and I kind of give
that to him,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
I learned a lot about myself from,
from that fight even,
uh,
and then fights after that.
I've had a lot of tough way because going into himself,
I don't really,
uh,
I don't really put too much in the first round though,
man.
Before you got tired,
you had a mounted,
it was a,
it was a big first round for you.
Yeah.
But that was one of the fights where I,
if I would've listened to rob in that fight,
I would already be the champion and then everything would look different.
You know,
I would already fought McGregor by now.
Uh,
and then the whole sport,
would it look different?
I think,
uh,
but I didn't listen to him and I,
did he tell you that you didn't listen to?
He tried to tell me to calm down.
Like when you see me,
like walk out for that fight I was on that wouldn't even like on 10,
I was on 12.
I was on 12 from the morning that I woke up until,
you know,
the,
until the fight ended.
Uh,
and that adrenaline pumping that,
I mean,
I,
I never felt like that since.
I probably don't,
I don't really want to feel like that either.
Uh,
I was when I stepped into the arena that night,
you know,
we get there about two hours before the fight actually is going on.
I was ready to fight and when I was warming up,
I was ready to fight.
I was fighting people in the bag.
There was no warm up.
I was fighting.
No.
How much did that staff fuck with you?
I think it put me into a state of fight or flight because you were compromised
for days before,
you know,
not even just that,
that,
you know,
the day of the fight for me in a state for for days before where it made the
weight cut.
Uh,
so horrible.
Like,
because my body just trying to hold on to everything and trying to,
you know,
when I woke up that morning,
I was about one 62 I woke up at 5:00 AM Wayne's are at 9:00 AM I have to be one
55.
So I've got seven pounds to to cut in,
which is okay.
It's not too bad.
Cut about nine pounds of the day before.
I'm a little dehydrated.
I'm a little,
you know,
I'm a little already worn.
But uh,
as the way cut was going,
you know,
we got till about eight o'clock and I had only cut a pound and a half,
so I still want 61 in a half something at eight o'clock Wayne's or at nine
o'clock to the point where we got to do something.
So they start to put me in the bathtub just because we do most of our cuts in
the bath.
You know,
when you,
when you're in a high humidity,
you,
you're going to cut more water weight or are you going to sweat more?
Uh,
and water is obviously a hundred percent humidity.
Um,
so they start throwing bull and hot water because we couldn't get the water hot
enough to make me sweat Christ.
So we've just taken a kettles of,
of hot water and just pouring it on me.
Uh,
and you know,
doctors are in and out his twin 12 people in and out of the hotel room to make
sure I'm okay and to makes sure that I could cut the weight.
And I was just in such a,
like an adrenaline fucking like on 10.
I'm like,
just get on.
You know,
I'm screaming at everybody.
I literally,
I was in the tub,
I was crying like,
why?
But to me,
I was like,
there's no way I'm not making this weight and six pounds in about an hour,
maybe two hours,
cause that go wait in about nine o'clock or so.
Uh,
or I mean,
uh,
about nine 30,
10 or so,
um,
six pounds in two hours.
This,
it was brutal,
but I think that just kept me as such a,
such a 10 on my adrenaline level.
I never really understood how to bring it back down,
you know?
And,
and rob would try and talk to me and try and tell me like,
hey,
calm down.
Like,
you know,
take a few deep breaths.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm breathing.
Whatever I'm wet,
I wouldn't listen to it.
So now when did you know you had staff?
Uh,
the Sunday.
The Sunday of the fight.
Yeah.
On Day of the fight.
So you had a whole week to think about it almost.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think about it like that as to be honest with you.
Yeah.
Which just notice I noticed like a little,
uh,
just the bump and it,
and it got like really big and I thought a spider had bitten me or something.
Um,
and you know,
for,
for Sunday,
I just Kinda,
you know,
I didn't think about it.
I wasn't trained in that day,
so it was nothing.
When I went in on Monday,
uh,
Dewey was actually the one,
Dewey Cooper,
my striking coach.
He was the one that kind of notice it.
And he was like,
Hey,
is that all right?
And you know,
uh,
and then rob,
when he took a look at it,
he was like,
oh yeah,
that's that staff for sure.
And,
uh,
you know,
I just kind of,
what do you do when that happens if you can't,
if you decided not to take antibiotics.
Yeah.
So what do you do?
I roughed it.
I was like,
you didn't put anything topical on it or was there,
was there a scratch that got infected or cut?
Honestly,
I have no idea what that,
just,
when I woke up on Sunday,
it was just,
was sticking out of my chest till about a boat right here in it.
I thought it was a spider bite or something,
you know,
I had never really had staff like that before.
Um,
I knew guys who had headed,
especially through college wrestling,
uh,
those rooms are just so dirty and filthy.
Um,
that I seen other people with it,
but it didn't look like that,
you know what I mean?
Normally look like a,
a a yard.
Um,
you know,
you have an open wound or something and then that'll get yellow and pissy and
disgusting.
But this was underneath my skin,
so it was not like an open wound or anything.
Um,
when I talk to doctors they said it was just on the layer of muscle,
I guess or or something.
Um,
and kind of sticking out from it.
at the time I didn't really know what that meant.
Like he said it was staff and I was like,
okay,
you know,
like I still feel good.
Like I could still move around.
Like we hit pads that day.
I've still felt good,
you know,
I can,
I was like,
I'm showing up to fight,
you know,
I,
when I was doing something,
anything on it or there's no,
so for six days he just trained and did everything with that staff.
And that was kind of like the last thing on my mind.
Even know I was there to fight when I,
when I,
when I signed the contract,
I,
I'm showing up to the fight.
Like I haven't pulled out of a fight yet.
Uh,
when I say I'm gonna do something,
I'm,
I'm going,
I'm going to go ahead and do it regardless of if my leg was halfway falling off.
It's like,
shit,
I still got another one.
You know,
I still got five more tells on the other leg,
so.
Right.
But looking back on it now,
are you happy that you made the decision that you made?
Oh yeah.
It wasn't smart,
but you know,
you would've done it again tomorrow.
Yeah,
I would have done it again.
no doubt.
No doubt.
I mean,
first world title fight,
you know,
to do anything to prevent staff.
Do you use like defense soap or anything like that?
Yeah.
Ever since he actually hooked me up with,
uh,
with those guys.
A defense.
Uh,
glad you did that.
Yeah.
They've been great to celebrate.
Uh,
I shot the guy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's Taco there also.
So now I'd just take way more preventive.
Uh,
uh,
yeah,
I haven't had anything flare up on me since probiotics here and there,
here and there.
I a good way to prevent that as well.
It also helps prevent ringworm.
I try,
I try my best to eat as many natural foods,
uh,
in especially like a lot of yogurts and Kiefer's one of them.
Cool.
Uh,
so,
you know,
I try and stay on top of it and uh,
at least I not know flare up has been happening since,
you know,
I shower every time.
I make sure like I'm on top of it.
I'll make sure I break my soap in the shower because you don't want that again.
It's mostly the,
the,
you know.
Yeah.
The fight didn't go my way or whatever.
Uh,
but it was about three or four weeks after that fight where I was just random.
I was wrecked.
I was just don't worship ever.
And when,
when,
when I got on those antibiotics,
I just fucking kills people.
Styling stuff kills.
Yeah.
It was terrible.
People that ignore staff,
I want to scream at him.
I'm like,
listen man,
you could die this.
It seems like you just got an infection,
but that shit gets systemic.
It gets in your bloodstream and you could fucking die.
One of my friend Brian Collins,
friend's wife died and he went over the house and she was like,
you know,
some people get crazy with holistic stuff.
Oh,
she's just going to try and natural healing.
And he's like,
get her do a fucking doctor.
He's like,
her gums were bleeding Jesus.
Yeah.
It had gotten systemic and she wound up dying.
Geez.
Yeah,
man.
From staff.
I've had it twice.
And,
uh,
the first time I had at,
I see when I got on the antibiotics,
first of all the antibiotics just kick ass.
The fact that Luke Rockhold won the fucking title against Chris Weidman while he
was on antibiotics shows you what a stud that guy is.
Yeah.
Cause that shit kicks your ass.
He had,
he had staff when he fought Weidman and to know that actually,
yeah,
he was wrecked.
Wrecked.
Oh No,
no.
Sorry.
Botics mess you up bad.
I've done it once for like a sore throat or,
or something.
Uh,
earlier,
um,
couple of years ago and it just wrecked me bad.
So I knew like going into that fight,
I was like,
I'd rather have the staff than the antibiotics.
I have asked that before.
I've had antibodies.
I know what they gonna do to me.
I was thinking that when you fought and afterwards talking to you about it,
I think you probably made the right move to not do antibiotics.
But I don't know,
I'm not a doctor,
but I was thinking that,
that it just weakens you so much.
You know,
it's just you live and learn from these things.
I think,
you know,
and this is just part of the,
the journey.
And before I would have like that where I wanted everything to be perfect or,
and I wanted everything to kind of be the way I saw it,
you know,
uh,
especially like starting out the career,
like everybody wants to be Floyd and when you 50 and know and,
and it's just,
you're not getting touched and it's just easy.
But then when you take a look back at that and you don't see like how many
amateur fights Floy head,
you know,
he's got his dad who fought,
he's got his uncles and his whole family had been fighting.
So He's learned from all their mistakes and all their losses and everything to
where it's like I'm the first one in my family to even ever think about this.
So you're going bump your head a here and there,
and it just says
comparison is the thief of joy.
You can't,
you can't do that.
You've got to just think about being the best that it is hard.
It's very hard to be inspired by people,
but comparing yourself to their path,
everybody's got a different path.
Everyone's got different genetics,
right?
Some people are just better at certain things.
Some people are,
some people struggle with certain aspects of the sport.
I mean that's,
it's,
everyone's got their own individual challenge and it's one of the things that's
so interesting about it is watching people adapt and grow.
And so you're in that stage right now,
right?
You're still young.
You're still a top contender is still one of the best fighters in the division,
and you just have to kind of figure out what you're going to do and how are you
going to do it.
So what are you thinking right now?
So I'm leaving a straight from here.
I'm going to go to Phoenix,
uh,
for about a week and work with John Child Crouch.
Great.
Yeah.
Love that guy.
Yeah,
he's great and outstanding.
Even seeing the way his coach has died,
I've never worked with them before,
but we have a mutual kind of respect.
Um,
I fought a couple of his guys before and,
and,
uh,
so he's definitely some masters.
He's one of the guys I want to pick his brain a in.
I kind of want to go to a couple of different places and just see how they are.
You know,
I'm gonna go from there to,
uh,
to Colorado and worked with Trevor Whitman.
Excellent.
Um,
and then go right to a Montreal and work with [inaudible].
That's what's up.
I love three though.
All three of maker great minds.
Um,
as I go to each place,
I'm gonna kind of see what I like and what I don't like about each one.
You know,
and see how they see how everything is there,
you know,
the life and,
uh,
w what training partners in,
in all these other things because that's just as important too,
so
absolutely.
Yeah.
I think also a shock to the system is important.
Like moving,
going to a new camp,
going into a new environment because you want,
you want to shine and all of a sudden you realize like,
man,
everything's on the line here.
Like you've literally uprooted your life,
move to some new place,
and it makes you be more dedicated.
It makes you realize you can't just fuck off here.
Like this is,
this is the real world.
You're a real world class fighter and you're,
you're on your path to attempt to become a world champion.
And this is the best way to do it.
I think it's so critical for fighters to make decisions and make changes and
make moves when they know that they,
they have a missing piece of the puzzle.
You know,
they're the Ma,
they're missing a master coach or they're missing a,
you know,
a great wrestling coach or a great striking,
cool,
whatever,
whatever the fuck it is.
A great environment with world class fighters,
whatever it is.
Have you talked to Jackson's?
Have you talked to those guys at all?
I haven't.
Um,
but you know,
I know a brain Gibson down there and I've been wanting to work with him for his
excellent long time.
Yeah.
Um,
I might,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know.
Uh,
this is,
this,
this little trip is going to take up six weeks at a time and then I figured when
I get back to Vegas and kind of regroup and be able to make some decisions from
narrow in on what's going to happen,
um,
I haven't done something like this until I,
since I've moved to Vegas in the first place where I just kind of packed up my
car and just start driving west.
Uh,
and you know,
was sleeping out on my corner before that,
I was still in Detroit from Detroit,
right to Vegas.
I was still in college when I got the call.
So,
you know,
that was like the time where I'm like,
I don't know which way my life is going to go.
You know,
I had,
I had got done with the fight with an owl.
I acquaint to my debut and after that fight I was like,
I gotta make some changes.
I just didn't know what.
And that was just as scary a time as now,
you know,
even though now like I ain't,
I ain't sleeping on my car,
you know what I mean?
I,
and I eat whatever I can.
I get you some Nice,
uh,
I can go to restaurants and,
you know,
but it still kinda feels the same,
it's still that same,
uh,
is scary,
you know,
and no lie because I don't necessarily know what it's gonna look like,
but I never really let that stop me.
The,
so what about top team?
You've thought about
dot all I have.
I mean,
I know a lot of guys that moved down to Florida.
Um,
you know,
the problem with Florida's is he's too nice suits.
Nice.
Yeah.
It's still like really crazy freaks down there.
But you know,
people say the same thing about Vegas too though.
You know,
when I first moved to Vegas,
uh,
I think Dana had did an interview or something maybe like a month after I moved
there and he was saying how hard it is for fighter to make it from Vegas.
And even at the time I was like,
no,
really nothing to me.
Like I don't really,
I try to stay focused,
you know,
I mean I,
I try and keep a bigger,
bigger picture,
uh,
in my head.
I don't really let the shit get to me too much.
So if I do move down to Florida,
I don't think I'm a just be on a beach kind of sat back.
I see some guys do it,
you know what I mean?
I've seen guys moved down there and just get caught up in that lifestyle of
sitting back as just,
it seems to me that Vegas,
if you stay away from this trip,
you'd be all right.
Yeah.
But Miami's the whole strip.
Yeah,
true.
Might be a little harder.
It's everything.
It's all of Miami.
And that's the attitude down there.
Everybody just parties,
Matt.
Yeah.
It's everybody else too.
That's,
it's a big influence.
Harris
from a,
what is this a pro production inside with a fighter's life?
Is that what it is?
A 95,
five minute fighting anatomy of a fighter.
He was just telling me about it.
He just went down there and he was thinking about moving there until like,
he spent like four days there and he's like,
get the fuck outta here.
I can't live here.
This is crazy.
These people are crazy.
He said,
you should need a passport.
I'm like,
that's what I would say.
It's like a different words.
A different country there.
It's a party country down there.
I've,
I've only been once to Miami.
Uh,
I've got a cousin that litter and uh,
I mean I went out with the intention of partying,
but I was like,
whoa.
I mean obviously it's looked good on it tomorrow.
Uzman mom lives there.
You can be a champion out of there.
Robbie Lawler's from there you can be a champion out there.
It's one of the best gyms in the world,
but it's in terms of distraction,
it does the hard part for,
for uh,
places like that is I'm missing that mind.
Do you know what I mean?
Uh,
they got a lot of great fighters Downer and they got a lot of,
I feel like the training and in,
in the uh,
uh,
atmosphere and you know,
the train of partners and everything would be great.
But I'm missing that,
that,
that great mind.
And,
and you know,
Mike Brown,
I,
I've,
I've met Mike a few times and there was,
this guy goes back,
but we haven't really like,
yeah,
she has a conversation with him,
have a conversation with him too.
I mean,
if you want to really decide what clicks with you better.
I'm,
I'm a big fan of Mike Brown and obviously Ricardo Laborio was fantastic,
Jujitsu coach and,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm just a whole fan of the whole organization,
you know,
when the way they put it together,
you know.
Mm.
Yeah.
I mean,
it could be a,
it might be something that I might look at.
You know,
it may,
maybe towards the end of the summer or something like that,
kind of already got this trip,
uh,
set in plants.
So I'm just like,
I'm about to pull the trigger on it and see where to take me.
Beautiful.
Wow.
I'm very glad that you're doing that.
You're making changes and,
and,
and trying to see,
you know,
where the right spot is for you.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
immediately after the fight is like when it,
when it doesn't go your way or the way you,
that you necessarily see it is,
it's discouraging is all hail,
you know,
you're like,
fuck,
I don't know if I'm doing the right thing.
I don't know if I'm seeing him right.
You know?
Uh,
before the fight in the locker room,
and this doesn't happen very often,
but I just,
I felt like I was seeing certain things and,
and,
and I don't necessarily,
I'm not a religious guy like that or anything and I don't really like believe
in,
I don't necessarily know what,
but when,
when certain things started to click for me,
like when you're on your way to work and you just like you hitting every green
light and then like,
you know,
somebody comes up to you,
they're going to say something,
you know what they're going to say,
and then you've got the,
the,
the time for the perfect answer.
It was kind of like that type of,
of,
of feeling that I was having.
So I just felt like everything was like coming together.
Right.
And my confidence was like boosting up so much before going,
you know,
I think the warm up was perfect.
The weight cut was,
you know,
it really wasn't a weight cut is everything was perfect going into the fight.
So then when it didn't go my way,
it's like,
it was discouraging a little bit.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
fuck,
I didn't know what I necessarily was doing wrong or,
or,
or if I was on the right path,
you know?
But
which leads you to think that you need a coach.
Yeah.
I need somebody smarter than me.
That's just the
man of everybody's smarter than you.
That's not you.
They can see you in a way that you can see.
Yeah.
Your friends are always smarter than you.
It's just,
hey man,
you got to stop doing that.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
You're fucking up like really?
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
You don't see it cause I'm in it.
Like how do I know that's his life,
man.
That's life.
I mean,
it's so important to have people around you that understand you and know you.
Yeah.
If you don't have.
And then also someone that you really trust and appreciate as a coach.
So gigantic man.
Yeah.
I think,
and especially for fighting because fighting is such a,
a personal thing to me.
You know?
It's not like,
that's why I never really worked with,
uh,
any of the guys at the UFC.
Pei,
like they've got everything there and they've got,
you know,
and even the coaches are great and all,
but it's like,
I need that.
I need to be able to trust you with my life.
Like that's really what it is.
Like no one's died inside the octagon yet.
But knock on wood,
knock on wood.
Yeah,
this nice table.
Oh Shit.
I had a lot of crazy fights,
you know?
So when I get up,
get ready to do it,
I go into it with that expectation.
You know,
if you're the one,
you don't care how many people haven't died doing it,
you know,
you're,
it's hundred percent for you,
the chances.
So I need to be able to trust every,
I need to trust you with my life almost,
you know?
And uh,
you know,
it's,
it's
hard to find that though.
The reason why I recommended for us a hobby is,
first of all,
he's one of the smartest guys I've ever talked to him.
It was for us as it fucking genius.
Legitimate Genius knows everything about MMA.
I mean there's not a stone unturned.
And he coached GSP.
And I feel like your style and GSP style are very similar and that you both are
very good wrestlers and you both very good at mixing up the wrestling and the
striking or you don't see anything,
you don't know what's coming and you're both,
you both don't have any weaknesses.
You have an awesome submission game.
GSP as an awesome submission game.
You have great wrestling,
great striking.
It's very similar.
And I think that his experience and coaching,
one of the greatest of all time and George St Pierre would,
would lend,
would just slide right into coaching someone like you.
I really,
I believe that.
Yeah.
I think for Ra as I'm getting closer to it,
you know,
I'll know more when I,
when I get there,
but that's the last stop.
Yeah,
stop on it.
That's the best stop.
And kind of the longest of it too.
Yeah.
I kind of had already thought that if I was a young man and I was thinking about
fighting,
I think I'd moved to Montreal.
Yeah.
No,
I think he's got a special mind.
I do.
You know,
and I,
and it's not to take away from any of the brilliant coaches.
I mean,
I think you can be a world champion with Duke Roufus who's also brilliant guy
and an amazing coach.
I mean,
there's no bad stop for you,
but there's just something about you and for us,
a hobby that I just,
yeah,
when I met him,
uh,
and I sat next to him,
we had dinner together.
Soon as I sat down next to him,
he told me everything I did wrong and atony fight like right out the gate.
And I was like,
Bingo.
Right.
I mean,
he's but genius.
He's sharp.
He's smart.
Yeah.
Uh,
so yeah,
I mean,
but then again,
Whitman,
I,
I've,
I've worked with Whitman to in Whitman is a really experienced dude.
You know,
he's,
he's coached so many people,
you see so many different styles and done it himself a lot too.
So,
you know what I love about Whitman,
when Justin gauge the flat lines,
people,
Whitman acts like nothing even happened.
Yeah.
It was like,
he knew it was going to happen.
It's crazy.
Like everybody's jumping and cheering and women like,
Yup.
I think it's cause he's saying so many,
he may have had been on the other side of that too,
where you know,
it's your guy getting knocked out too.
So,
you know,
it's like you said,
it's two people going in there.
If somebody got to lose.
So He's been around the game long enough to where he understands the other side
of it too,
as you know,
he ain't going to go crazy.
And you know,
uh,
because that guy's got a family,
that guy's got people they try and take care of.
He's got every other motivation that you got to,
you know.
Yeah.
Really?
Um,
I think Dell is also the culture shock.
Moving to Montreal will be good for it too.
Yeah.
I mean maybe,
uh,
I bet I spent some time
cold as fuck.
So I left Detroit.
Yeah.
Oh no worries.
Oh my God.
I've been to Montreal and January.
It's like,
yikes.
That's outside.
You got that thick fog coming out of your mouth.
Good.
Whew.
That's,
I'm going to Joe
now and June.
But for you,
man,
I think it's good for you.
I feel like that that coal,
my,
it might be something today,
you know,
the best wrestlers and everything are always from the Midwest and in from net
code.
And you know why?
Because he developed character.
Yeah.
I think it is something to that it's 100% soft ask people out here in college
when Bro.
Yeah.
Vegas.
No difference by all my friends from Boston that come out to California.
People are fucking soft out here.
Yeah.
They don't have to shovel snow and have to worry about freezing to death.
You know,
if your car breaks down in Boston,
you 10 miles from your house,
you might freeze to death.
Yeah.
That's real.
You better keep a blanket in that bitch.
Yeah.
You've got to be tough and sleeping bag and a candle.
And I think it gives you like different,
different morals and different lights,
different character to you.
You know,
you,
you value things a little bit differently.
So in that code,
you know,
Detroit was the same way.
It's like seven months out the year and you spending that time indoors in unity.
It's like your family and everything cause you ain't going to be inside with
some fucking Schmo from down the street and you don't want to count on each
other too when it gets fucking cold.
Yeah.
Cause everybody's in this together.
Literally,
literally all his fucking coal.
We ain't going up there.
It's also like a a vulnerability to nature that just forces you to accept your
place in the universe like you are.
You are vulnerable.
You're very vulnerable.
In California,
your wife could kick you out.
You're like,
fuck you bitch.
I'll sleep on the lawn.
You can go sleep in the law and you don't have to worry about nothing.
You know,
you'd be fine.
January you could sleep on the lawn with a good jacket on in California was
gorgeous too.
You can just get in your car,
just drive down to the beach and yeah,
exactly.
She live in in a mean to me,
I think it's paradise but too easy.
But then you talk to people who,
they spent their whole life here and they don't see it that way.
So maybe it's all perfect.
Brazil.
I mean,
how bad ass or people from Brazil,
and that's fucking paradise too.
Yeah.
But it's rough,
rough paradise.
It's a little different down in Brazil,
you know,
I think a lot of crime.
Yeah.
I get them.
Resilience,
a lot of respect.
They,
they,
you know,
some of them,
they really,
uh,
they come up out of nothing,
you know,
and literally out of nothing.
And to build that respect around a they community and stuff.
I give it to them.
I do as well.
And you know,
you've got to give it up to them for creating Brazilian Jujitsu.
I mean,
they,
they essentially revolutionized Jujitsu.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
the Gracie family is the most important family in the history of martial arts
and what they did with Brazil and Brazilian Jujitsu and how Brazilian Jujitsu
evolved in that country.
You know,
just,
they took to it like a duck to water man.
Yeah.
I wonder what it is about,
uh,
Brazil that,
that,
that was like the one place to stay.
You know,
I,
I think that if they,
if that count,
my ada had gone anywhere else.
If he had landed and talked to some other dudes somewhere,
I think they got lucky.
They found Alien Gracie and Carlos Gracie and they found some dudes who would
just straight up warriors and they taught those guys.
And those guys were,
I mean,
Leo Gracie,
just really him and Carlos just thought it through and then we're willing to
test it in real competition against people much larger than them.
The fact that Leo was a small man,
he wasn't a large framed man,
is the reason why Brazilian Jujitsu became so effective because Leo had to fight
off of his back.
He had a tire out bigger guys.
First they had,
uh,
developed,
the concept of cooking your opponent.
You know,
all that wasn't in Japanese Jujitsu.
It wasn't in judo.
Judo is a beautiful,
elegant martial arts with fantastic technique and powerful moves,
but wasn't Brazilian Jujitsu.
Brazilian Jujitsu is largely a part of this one dynamic,
incredible family.
And if you look at that family,
all the fucking champions Hoists Horian Hixon you know,
I mean,
come on Matt Hoy crazy and now crone.
Yeah,
I mean Jesus Christ.
What a fucking family man.
Hens.
So yeah.
Yeah,
I mean high end.
I mean just it just Gracie after Gracie,
you saw Gracie like oh no killers.
Just straight killers.
Yeah.
I mean the game has changed a little bit.
It says,
don't forget Carlson Gracie to the game of shades,
a little bit system.
But it has been because of them.
I felt sure
it's evolved in that area and sprung out.
And of course,
you know,
obviously there's,
Moyie Thai from Thailand,
Dutch kickboxing,
American wrestling,
there's so many different factors,
Russian wrestling,
so many different factors that come into what we now call mixed martial arts
today.
But man,
I just keep thinking that if it wasn't for that one family who the fuck knows
because the part of what made the ultimate fighter so spectacular or the
ultimate fighting championship rather in,
in the first two ones was hoists Gracie being this guy who's not this physically
terrifying guy.
Like give it was Mark Coleman.
If Mark Coleman
to 65 with muscles up to his neck is straight up to the top of his head,
his neck would just like come off of his shoulders.
He was huge.
If he won,
you'd be like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
But when hoists one,
everybody was like,
shit,
I gotta learn Jiu Jitsu.
Yeah.
Like look,
that guy choked that dude out.
What?
His legs?
Yeah.
Like I remember people at home were going,
what the fuck is this
mixed fighting?
So great.
Cause you never know what's gonna,
what's gonna happen in real fuck,
you know?
True.
Sure.
I mean,
even in boxing until,
you know,
you see some,
some crazy shit like Anthony Joshua just beat.
Uh,
but it,
you know,
but I think in MMA it's,
it's,
it's even more just cause there's so many different options.
And I have a poem from a good source that Anthony Joshua got dropped in sparring
the week of the fight.
Wow.
And he got hurt real bad the week of the fight and that he was very tentative
coming into that fight and very vulnerable.
Which makes sense.
You could kind of see it on them a little bit.
You know,
when first round when you,
when you even walking out,
you know,
you can kind of see his,
his look and it's a little glazed and it's a little a little out of it.
You know,
I figured that it was just coming over to America for the first time and you
know,
being in,
in,
in New York and,
uh,
it's a lot of,
that's a lot of pressure and a lot of,
uh,
you know,
especially when you talk about Deontay Walder like knocking the dude into until
like the next century,
like the week before because you see,
oh,
you're like,
fuck,
I got a fight.
Yeah.
Did you see that video that I posted on Instagram from the duty?
Does animation and Nona,
oh my God,
this is too amazing ones pull up.
First of all,
pull up the Deontay wilder one cause he has a,
the the fucking glove from a,
the Avengers and he,
he hits this dude.
This guy did this.
Yeah,
Ray,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Not Credible.
Yeah,
he's crazy.
That guy's animate on his graphics are amazing.
But uh,
he did one for Deontae and then he did an even more hilarious one for Andy Ruiz.
Oh my God.
See the Andy?
I did see the one with the [inaudible].
Uh Oh you saw that one?
Okay,
so pull up,
pull up the Ruiz one then.
Yeah.
So you could see when he,
when he drops Joshua,
watch this shit.
It's hilarious man.
The guy's so good.
Give us some volume too.
Can we do that or was it the,
the soundtrack to do you think we'll get in trouble for that?
Yeah.
No volume.
All right.
Just play the video.
Watch this.
So
is he even the way when you look in a Joshua after the faculty of this,
and then if he,
his body,
his body's still there,
but his spirit,
he's got a roller roller bag.
Let's go through the airport.
His spirit has got tweety birds floating around his head.
Why?
Anthony?
Joshua was still on the ground.
His spirit gets into a plane and flies away.
That was awesome.
That guy.
That dude's awesome.
It's so amazing how he did that.
The next day,
the day after the fight that was out.
People are getting crazy or like what they can do.
Yeah.
It makes you jealous a little bit.
It's like,
I know.
Right.
You know,
wish I even had that kind of create a process to think it through it,
let alone like go through with it,
you know?
I know he brought that crazy.
That guy's a master though,
is his ability to,
to here's the Deontay wilder one.
Yeah.
I mean that is crazy.
And then when Deontae moves away with the eyes glowing,
that's awesome.
He has the craziest power I've ever seen in the heavyweight division.
He's so weird.
It's so weird.
His Pie and you know when he fought Tyson fury wait two oh nine yeah.
That's all I really,
two Oh nine wow.
Crazy.
Yeah.
And wasn't trying to be light either.
He just,
that's just what he wound up weighing.
I think he's one of those guys.
I can find your Chin like certain guys like have a weird kind of,
you know,
these kind of Ganglia.
Anyway,
but he,
he can,
they punches.
I coming from od and he goes,
he's got the power and everything too,
but it's more than power.
It's like he's fine.
Any a chin in there and it's good Chin finding intelligent.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's got that home seeking missile.
You know the fact that he dropped Tyson fury like that in the 12th round of a
fight where he was kind of getting out box other than dropping him once,
but the way he hit him in that 12th round,
I was like,
God damn,
he knocked him out in the 12th round.
I look at that and I'm like to not get discouraged.
You know what I mean?
Like that's some serious belief in the type of power that you got.
If after 12 rounds you ain't landed the shot and you can still kind of muster it
up in in the 12th it's as a fighter.
I kind of look it down like damn.
Like that's a lot of of of you got to give it to them.
Like you can't take your hat off to him.
It's like he's got crazy endurance too.
That's the other thing.
He must have a phenomenal work ethic because he's never tired and he carries
that power deep into the 12th round.
Yeah.
The a lot of times guys that hit real hard like that,
after you get past six,
seven rounds,
they start to fade,
especially in the heavyweight division.
But Deontae moves just as fast hits just as hard in the 12th as he does in the
first.
It might be something to,
uh,
keeping keeping his weight to like that.
Like you said,
he's only 209 pounds.
He was heavier for this fight for the Dominic Brazil fight.
Apparently he was,
he was quite a bit heavier.
Uh,
how much of you do you think you,
I think it was two 30 or something that does a lot of weight.
Yeah.
See what he weighed a wood what?
Deontay wilder waitin for Dominic Brazil,
I think.
I think that I was kind of shocked that he was just somewhere in the two
thirties,
which is like a normal heavyweight.
Two 2123 Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Now much still still,
still,
still a little bit of weight,
but until someone's to 18 member when he was in his prime,
Tyson wasn't even two to 20.
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
I think it's,
uh,
it's definitely something to that,
you know,
maybe a,
uh,
that's just what their natural weight is.
You know,
I think it's,
as I'm getting a little bit more deeper into the game,
it might be some tasks.
One think I'm gonna stay at one 70.
Uh,
even from now,
I think you've,
you show up healthier and it's,
it's just if you got that experience,
if you've already been fighting a lot of heavyweights,
like I,
he has,
it's not like a 265 pounds,
dude is going to shock them.
You know what I mean?
Or to 40 or,
well,
it's also because there's no wrestling.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That it's,
it's a big factor in it.
Um,
yeah,
I think it's a giant factor.
Yeah.
But then again,
look at Cain Velasquez.
When Kane was at his prime,
he was about two 40.
And you know,
when he fought Brock Lesnar,
Brock Lesnar was quite a bit bigger than him,
but it didn't matter.
I mean,
cane fault.
A lot of guys who are bigger than them.
Yeah.
The,
the wrestling is,
is probably the biggest reason I think a lot of us cut weight in him and May for
sure.
I mean,
that's,
that's where,
uh,
that's where you can feel the most weight to,
you know,
when,
when I was going against,
uh,
the sod,
Josias,
it's like I didn't necessarily feel he was any stronger than me or any stronger
than any 55 pounder that have fought before.
Uh,
but when,
when I kind of would have them pressed or whatever and I could kind of feel the,
the,
the weighted at,
uh,
you know,
all my back and,
and just carry it.
Um,
and it makes you expend more energy to,
you know,
I think it's like fighting with a pound vest on.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Wait,
when the fight was over,
he,
that's the first thing you said to me.
He's like,
yeah,
I knew coming up to two,
one 70,
just being your first fight that he was going to get tired.
And I was like,
Eh,
I could have told me that before you with,
they don't do me no good man.
He's got some phenomenal cardio though.
And also he was coming off the [inaudible] fine.
Bustamante outworked him.
Yeah.
So he's probably like extra geared up.
Yep.
And it was much bigger than me too,
you know.
And uh,
so he,
he,
he had already felt that.
Yeah.
And he's,
he's fought for the title that one seven.
He's got a lot of fights at one 70 already,
so he's already felt that that weight gone
through.
Uh,
nick [inaudible] strength and conditioning routines.
You know,
he was a,
I don't know if he's still working with nick curse on,
but nick curse on was a Marv Marinovich disciple and just fun.
They do a lot of crazy box jumps and plyometrics.
You ever seen him on Instagram?
No.
Go to a speed of sport on Instagram.
I know he did a lot of work with Aaron Peko before Pico.
Went to cal Avida.
He was doing work with him.
He's done a lot of work with a lot of profilers.
Did I think he worked with Joe Schilling and he's worked with a lot of guys,
but wild strength and conditioning shit a lot apply owes a lot of box jumps in a
lot of crazy shit where you,
you know that,
that a calf raise bar and they,
they'll do that.
But with your feet like kick it up and down and up and down.
Like let me see,
would see what you got there Jamie.
This is just some of the shit that he has people do.
Is this dose on Joe's?
Yeah.
So he was,
I wonder if he was training with him for this fight,
but it's a lot of this type of shit.
It's a lot of uh,
explosive plyometric shit.
And his idea is that when you're in a fight,
see this thing,
like they're doing a lot of stuff with that thing and they'll do it laying on
their back with their feet as well.
But it's all this just explosive bouncing stuff.
And I mean his philosophy,
he doesn't ever have those guys lift weights like traditional lifting weights.
It's all like Plyo box jumps,
exploding,
jumping over hurdles,
that kind of shit.
Intense,
intense stuff.
But it's,
that's the stuff that got Bj Penn into the best shape of his life.
When Bj Penn fought Sean Sherk,
when Bj Penn fought Diego Sanchez when he was at the top of the food chain,
Bj was working with Marinovich his and he was doing all this crazy cardio
workout,
which was like the missing link in Bj's arsenal because before Bj's is
incredibly talented guy.
But then he just didn't have the same kind of work ethic and cardio and he just
gave himself to Marinovich and just like,
go ahead dude,
tell me what to do.
And mostly what they were doing with strength and conditioning and they were
saying basically Bj already knows how to fight and the real key was to get his
gas tank is fucking thick and fat as possible.
Just give him this giant ass gas tank and give him this capacity to work.
That's just unprecedented to him.
And then everything else,
he already knows how to do.
So everything else,
just do it light,
but don't compromise on the strength and conditioning workouts cause that's the
most important aspect of the sport.
And it's a very,
it's a very controversial discussion.
Well,
what's most important?
Yeah,
I think need balance with
it all,
you know,
so two by you as the cal vetoes methods,
uh,
for this one and came down to see him a couple times in Orange County.
Uh,
which stuff did he have you do?
That dude's a fucking,
he's a man of his workouts are brutal,
his ideas are,
are more,
he takes you to exhaustion and then we do stuff like that,
like the explosive stuff in,
in,
uh,
different types of movements and you know,
kind of making sure that your legs are still underneath you,
but he puts you on a bike and in that bike workout is,
it's like a 30 minute,
uh,
three minutes,
like keeping a hard,
hard pace on like a very,
very high level.
And,
you know,
he's got you strapped up with all these monitors and everything to,
to Kinda make sure that you actually hit in your red line and then the workout
starts.
So it's about like a three hour workout in is draining.
It's brutal.
It's like three hours.
Yes.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
you,
you see some things going through a workout like that,
you know what I mean?
Like you go to a,
like a dark dark in it.
I went through a couple of them getting ready for that fight.
Uh,
wages takes with Aaron Peko.
Yeah,
that's his garage through,
that's where we,
uh,
do the workout.
Nomy it's a brutal,
uh,
he took a lot of shit after TJ tested positive for EPO.
Well,
shit,
I can see why I needed it.
I had to go through some of,
I was like,
shit,
I see,
you know,
like,
ah,
you know,
each his own and all that.
Uh,
but you know,
I don't put that on Sam.
It's like,
you know,
in camp.
Yeah.
I mean,
teachers,
a grown man,
he's got to do what he's gonna do.
So I don't even know if he knew.
Yeah.
And,
and speaking with him and everything,
he had no idea.
He was just as blindsided,
which is,
you know,
kind of
that's,
that's unfortunate for him too,
because everybody was really paying attention to how,
how scientifically he was designing and engineering these workouts and people
were really excited about it.
So it was a,
you know,
a bit of a backstop for him as well.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he's a smart,
smart dude,
you know,
I think he's a,
a math teacher over it at cal state or,
or something like that.
Um,
I mean,
genius of a deal.
You sit and talk to them and they're like,
he's gone tell you exactly why he's running you through these,
these certain things.
So,
uh,
you know,
we,
we picked up on his,
uh,
philosophies going into this one.
And I,
you know,
even though I was tired during the fight,
it's a fight.
You're going to be tired.
I still have my legs underneath me and instill a could go,
you know?
Um,
so I don't know.
I think,
I think it was more tactically than anything if I'm going back on it.
But
you know,
you think it's more in the way you approach the pacing and the way you
approached like as far as like the strategy of how to face dos Anjos yeah.
What did you think was going to happen when you went into the fight?
I was going to break them.
Just going to run,
wanting to fight.
Like,
you know,
I think the fight before that with,
uh,
without,
um,
I hated the way that fight went.
I hated the way I,
I showed for it and I,
and I left way too much reserved in the worst feeling for me.
Like I don't really,
I hate losing,
I really do,
but I don't really get hung up on the results that much.
I hate not performance and
potential.
So if you feel like you performed to your potential and someone does better,
then you're like,
okay,
this a lesson.
Yeah,
I can learn from that and grow from it.
But when it's a fight and I get done with it when loser or whatever and I still
got a little bit in me and I still like,
you know,
you walk back to the doctor and I'm still ready to fight and I still feel that
enemy.
I hate that feeling more than anything.
So I wanted to make sure that I didn't get this one from this one.
You know?
And I haven't really,
uh,
had a fight in the UFC yet that is hit kinda where I want it to be.
You know,
like I haven't given,
people have watched me grow up in,
in the sport I feel like,
but they didn't really seem like a good fight out of me yet.
So that's Kinda what I was looking for.
And what I was after is just those central so smart about it and in and world
champion.
So,
but you know,
yeah.
I mean he's been around the block man.
He's smart and he's in a precarious situation himself.
Right.
Cause you get dominated by the champ and his last fight and you know,
I mean,
what do you do from there?
I mean he,
he beats you and,
but where is he?
It's not like people are clamoring for him to fight for the title again.
The good thing is at one 70th so many good fights to be at.
Like even for me as so many of,
you know,
he got asked her any you got,
you got uh,
uh,
Mazda at all that he's getting ready to fight you got was man,
you got Comoro,
you got pedes and Diaz is back and you know,
there's so many good fights.
I mean there's gonna be a great fight for him.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean,
I don't know that.
Yeah,
look at it like that.
No,
I'm pretty sure as well.
I mean God damn both divisions between 55 and 70 or stack,
you were pushing for a 65.
Yeah.
I think it's a great idea.
I still am Kinda [inaudible] too.
They just don't want to listen.
Nobody wants,
I think 16 change,
70 to 75 change.
(655) 054-0530 five it's makes sense.
10 pounds makes sense.
But these arbitrary,
I think that should be a 95 two how about that?
That one I can see a little bit just because of how shallow two oh five was
getting.
But now you've got so many great fighters at two oh five,
even a,
and you starting to see that body type that's coming through,
you know,
the Johnnie Walker,
uh,
the kid that just fought,
the,
the last,
uh,
last weekend and knocked out manual.
Yeah.
I don't know,
you know,
uh,
he just knocked out Jimmy Manoa but he's Kinda got that similar frame to as John
Jones and you know,
you starting to see more of those guys.
So
how do you say his name?
Yeah,
man.
Oh,
retired.
Okay.
Just show it to me and I'll spell it.
Oh,
Alexander rockets or breakage,
right.
All right.
Right.
Yeah.
Rakic I think its rocket.
He's a fucking beast,
man.
That's step in left high kick was beautiful.
Brutal.
But the,
but now they're getting so many guys that they might be able to build a 95.
Oh,
I said at one point,
but they could do 65 right.
Right here and now.
And it'll be okay.
You know,
one of the best.
Yeah,
it'd be hard,
but there's too many guys at 55 and 70.
Yeah.
I think that,
and then also like,
look at the women's flyweight division,
the women's or the women's with women's flyweight division.
Now,
of course,
with shift Gencos gonna Fight Jessica I this weekend,
but if you go back to the women's,
um,
uh,
strawweight division,
when Yolanda was champion,
everybody's like,
well,
there's no one there who's going to fight her and now it's stacked.
It's stacked.
You got Tatyana Smart as he got Jessica on drudge who just just beat it,
beat thug rose,
you know,
you've got,
so many fighters.
It's like,
it's a worldclass division.
It seemed like he got better too when they edit one 25.
Yes.
I mean,
it got,
it got even more because now you seeing like the people who wouldn't get Sean
before,
now they're getting shot at you.
Like,
oh,
like y'all got some serious talent.
And then,
you know,
and I,
and I felt like at 55 you've got so many guys that's underneath top 25 that
could,
could shine through,
you know,
if you just give them the space.
It,
it also allows for,
for guys to like Max Holloway to,
to go up at 55 and be able to compete at his,
I feel like that's more of his natural weight too,
you know,
is you get those four to 5% of the,
he lost the Dustin Poirier.
A lot of people were saying,
you know,
he just doesn't have the same power at 55 that he had at 45
I just don't think he had the experience yet.
You know,
I don't,
I don't think 55 yeah,
he,
that was his first fight at 55 so,
you know,
and Dustin's already had,
a lot of them were,
even if they had both fought at 45 before Dustin's already been there.
So he,
it wasn't,
it's not going to be a shock to him.
You know,
he kinda gotta just give credit to Dustin how fucking bitches.
That too.
A lot of people forgot was wrong the way he was rolling with punches and be just
barely slipping them power
or,
and once he's moved up to 55 and he was torturing himself to get to 45,
he's a great example of a success story of a guy who stopped cutting as much
weight.
But he's big now.
He's having a hard time making 15.
Yeah,
he's grown into the way classes.
Which Max,
we'll do the same,
you know,
Max a big dude like,
uh,
so I think if you,
if you let them compete against guys that are more his sausage and eventually
the next time that they fought,
I think it would look a little bit different.
And what do you think could be versus Dustin looks like?
Cause that's what they're setting out.
That's the next fight.
And Abu Dhabi,
I don't know.
I really don't know.
Like to say,
right?
Yeah.
Before the Max fight,
I would have for sure been like a beach is going to blow them out of the water.
Uh,
he's just going to take them down and she's going to be too big.
But like I said,
Haley wasn't trying to take him down the way it could be.
Well,
it's a difference.
It's a different fighter.
Yeah.
But,
but the way does his footwork was looking in the,
um,
that's what makes you think about it because,
you know,
could beeps kind of a one track one train mine,
he's going to come right at you.
You know,
he's going to do to,
uh,
but we,
if Dustin not even necessarily can,
can out wrestle him.
It's just,
it's way easier to play defense on wrestling then than offense.
And if you've got great footwork like that to,
to keep,
uh,
you're back off the fence.
Might be a long night for,
could be
who notified.
It's a good fight.
It's a fight.
Dustin's got that serious power.
Yeah.
It's a good time.
Dustin can hurt you.
Yeah.
And Paul's ag.
Yep.
You know,
Sao Paulo,
I think that's gonna play a big factor in it.
You know,
it's a little harder to get in on a lot of those shots.
The real key is can he stuffed the take down and can he defend himself on the
ground?
Cause it was so many guys could be gets a hold of them and then they developed
that thousand yard stare where they're like,
what in the fuck is happening?
You know how it's like when you mean especially,
I'm sure you remember early in your career when you would go with a guy who was
just way bigger than you are way stronger than you and you just go,
oh I can't do shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Is that I can't do shit thing.
I'm just sort of surviving.
Yeah.
I mean I still try and put myself into situations now.
It's a terrible feel.
You I'll roll with Robert Drysdale or something.
I'm like,
I'm lucky just to,
I'm just counting how many times or I rode with Vinny a malaise and I'm like,
I'm just trying my best not to get submitted.
Yeah.
I'm at the point where now you only go submit me one or two times.
You know,
before it was like 10 that goes like as many times as you want it to.
But you know,
like,
okay,
if I slowly pick at this and then,
you know,
my
so shocked he didn't win that Pfl thing.
I was so shocked.
I thought he was going to win it for sure.
Yeah.
He's striking has come so far.
You know,
it's one of those that,
you know,
it's the game.
It's the game.
The game.
Yeah.
What can you do?
It's a fucking crazy sport.
It really is the craziest sport that's ever existed.
You never know,
even as an athlete,
like you can do everything to,
to prepare.
Right.
And you feel like all the chips in like everything's in your corner.
And like,
I mean,
I guess it's like life.
It's like you think everything is just right,
but sometimes it's not shit half.
Look,
can you do pick it up and try it again?
Like a map?
Yeah.
Well you just have to accept that this is what you've chosen.
You know?
And this is part of what comes with it.
It's just chaos.
I think you just gotta be crazy.
I think that'd be a little,
you gotta be a little like out of your fucking mind to do this.
Yeah,
100%.
But I mean I see other people in other professions and what they do and I'm
like,
he's a little crazy too.
You know what I mean?
He's a little out of his mind to do what he doing.
Yeah.
So maybe that's just what you just be me,
the freedom to not be stuck in the fucking office.
You have an exciting life is crazy and chaotic as it is.
Lease is exciting.
I'll take exciting every day off,
overboard
and it lets me be me,
you know what I mean?
Like that walking out full of fighter or just,
just even just getting ready for the like the week of and you know,
doing media and stuff like that and,
and just,
it lets me like really express myself in a way that I never really got to as a
kid or,
or,
or anything before that.
Uh,
where that gives me like a little bit peace and it gives me like,
I really don't give a fuck about nobody else are or what they are doing or what
they got going on in.
It lets me like just be me and just flow it in and just,
and just have fun before I would never really let myself do that,
you know,
to kind of always be guarded and I will kind of always be like,
like on edge and just not just be myself and fighting has let me,
let me let it out,
you know?
And not
because it's so crazy because it's a wild exchange because what you're doing and
so dynamic that you could just be the full,
you know?
Yeah.
And I think everybody is different too.
You know,
everybody fights different so,
so it's not one is better than the other,
you know,
it's not like,
it's like you just got to,
if you be yourself then and then you're going to do better,
you know what I mean?
Like,
even,
uh,
even in the media and stuff like that or,
or however you want to approach this,
like if you be yourself,
uh,
I kind of figured it out,
like,
just be me and just enjoy it.
Then it's,
then it's butter as opposed to like,
you know,
when you target in a microphone in front of you there,
it's like when you,
uh,
you know,
you're stuck in an office or whatever or,
or however it is,
are you stuck doing something that you feel like you should do or people want
you to do,
then you start like live in like that almost.
And I kind of have felt myself get there before I started fighting.
Uh,
it's like trying to live up to other people's expectations or,
or you know,
uh,
and fighting.
It's just like
you're free of your own destiny.
Yeah.
And a lot of ways,
yeah,
the best thing about it,
the fuck the wind fuck the laws of money is fun.
Uh,
that's kind of why I got into Info is fun,
but it is,
it's given me a lot of else to my life,
you know what I mean?
Right.
So do you watch many fights outside of ozone?
Yeah.
All Day.
Every day.
But outside of MMA?
Yeah.
I mean it's like Jujitsu or Moy Thai or
I watch all the,
uh,
Jujitsu when it,
when it's really getting going.
You know,
I was going to try and come out here a day before and try to see worlds.
Um,
you know,
it depends,
but yeah,
I try.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's interesting when you see how good people are at those individual
disciplines,
you know,
that's,
uh,
that's one of the more interesting aspects about MMA is that you really can't be
the best in the world.
That everything and you're going to have,
because it's such a complex chart.
Yeah.
You can try it.
You certainly can.
But you're right though.
I think a lot of a lot of these other sports and stuff,
they,
they've had so many years just to figure out what works and what don't work,
that they've really refined the process.
You know what I mean?
Like you see somebody high,
high level boxers and it's like they've had,
you know,
you talk about somebody like Floyd,
he's had his,
his dad fight and his,
his uncle fight before him to where he's like refined the process so much that
it's damn near perfect.
You know what I mean?
We haven't got to that point yet.
Inhibit may know it's going to be a while.
Not often while close,
not even close.
I don't know if we'll ever get there because it seems like it's because it's a
combination of so many different disciplines.
It's,
you just don't,
it doesn't seem like you're ever going to see the a guy who is worldclass Moitai
and worldclass Jujitsu and worldclass wrestling all in one fighter.
It just doesn't seem like that's really possible.
I think you can get it in a couple more generations though.
I think so.
And maybe like four more generations,
something like that.
Because it's like I look at the kids now that are coming up and they don't have
the same light preconceptions that,
that even I had,
uh,
coming up in it,
you know,
like where when if you boxing you box in this way and you know,
this is the right thing to do,
this is the wrong thing to do,
you know,
uh,
or,
or you taken,
you've taken so many things and you're not really,
you're kind of stuck on it.
You know what I mean?
And I feel like each generation is getting a little bit better,
a little bit better.
I look at like some of the things that kids do now,
I'm like,
fuck,
like I want to wish I could be debt free.
And it just kind of have that,
that creative process to do it,
you know?
Uh,
it's going to happen eventually I think.
Yeah.
With the little kids that are starting off like little amateur fights and then
like 10 years old and shit.
Yeah.
So then I think about his kid,
you know,
and what's it's gonna look like.
And then,
okay,
and then what's his kid going to look like?
A it to where you will get somebody who is,
who is just perfect and whatever they do.
That's a good point because it really is a big factor that Floyd had his dad who
was a worldclass Fido flush sugar ray Leonard and his uncle Roger was the black
Mamba mean Roger May,
where there was the fucking man back in the 80s.
And I want to see those two guys training him.
That is gigantic grown up in that environment,
always been around boxing
and they could tell them what to do and what not to do.
Even when you get to that certain level,
you know,
it's like,
it's,
you don't know what you don't know until it's too late almost.
Uh,
but you know,
he had people that he really respected like is,
is,
I mean you,
your uncle and your pops,
they're going to be the first people that you respect and you
listen to them.
So I think it played a huge factor that people don't really look at.
I think so too.
And it's also seeing their mistakes that other fighters have made.
When you're growing up in the gym,
you've seen guys that spar too hard or seeing guys that get hit too much or
seeing guys that take the wrong fire to thing.
Guys don't fight smart defensively.
You know,
one of the things that people forget is that Floyd went through a big transition
of his own.
If you go back to the early parts of his career and you watch when he was pretty
boy Floyd,
yeah,
he was a much more aggressive fighter and you would put himself in danger much
more.
And then when he became money Mayweather,
like as it got later and later in his life,
he just got so much more brilliant defensively and then he became the guy that
you see shutting out Canelo Alvarez stopping all these,
just just shutting
everything down.
He just became this defensive wizard to the point where you'd see world class
fighters like sugar Shane Mosey,
who did tag him,
but other than that,
didn't really know.
Once he,
once he recovered,
he didn't really know what to do with Floyd.
Floyd just had the answers to his style.
He had figured them out.
Yeah.
And I,
I have a see a lot of people,
uh,
a cause I,
I go by his gym from time to time,
you know,
it's,
and,
and I see like a lot of people that,
that are coming up in boxing who just want to right out the gate,
be what Floyd is now,
you know what I mean?
Be,
be on the ropes and be able to slip punches and,
you know,
and,
but they forget like the time when he beat the fuck out of our tour.
Oh God.
You know,
you know,
and was no defense to it.
He just came out and was throwing hands.
Like they forget all of the,
like amateur fights that he had before that,
that he's won and loss.
And you know,
he just had a different style of fighting.
So it's,
it takes time to get to that,
that,
that level.
You know what I mean?
Certainly the world get their flight was brutal.
Brutal.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a monster.
I give him a lot of respect.
I do.
Uh,
you know,
and I mean,
not a lot of people do,
but that's crazy.
Just be on him while he talks
slash shit.
But you got to separate that from what he does.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you watch him fight,
the guy is defensively spectacular.
Yeah.
He knows exactly when you watch the Canelo fight.
I've watched,
I can know if I'd at least three times.
And when you watch him stand in front of Canelo Canelo's throws a left,
he's over here,
he throws a right,
pop tick that Jab with you.
Oh,
and I'm back here and Chinelo is like,
just within the straw strong punches.
You could see the look in his face like,
God damn man,
I'm in here with a master.
Yeah.
This is a master boxer and I'm learning a lesson here.
The good thing is,
you know,
he learned that lesson the right,
right.
And now look at him.
Yeah.
Canelo's a monster dude.
Monster defensively to see some of his defense now.
And even me,
like I look at his head and I'm like,
God damn.
You know,
he said,
uh,
against Danny Jacobs.
Just,
just a little while ago,
like his head mobile is just on point.
That was a great fight cause Danny Jacobs,
he's a fucking kill him.
And I was pulling for Jacobs but I had to,
I had to give it to Canelo.
I'm like,
he really took what he learned from Floyd and you know,
sometimes you need that,
you know,
even like how you send me a Georgia are kinda similar.
I tried to pick a fight with a man.
Like I know I like,
I wanted to fight him of course,
because going into I was like a win,
lose or draw.
I'm gonna learn something from this month.
Boy,
he gonna know he was in a fight.
I'm going to show up,
I'm a give them everything I got,
but I knew just for the future,
unlike that,
a fight like that is just gonna propel you.
It's just going to get better.
You know,
you,
I think he's going to want to fight and could be probably,
I think so.
Probably.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
I think,
uh,
if Dustin Poray if could be beats Dustin poor Yay.
Could be is going to lobby for a fight
with George.
Yeah,
that's what I think beats George.
I think he's going to retire.
That's what I think.
I think it could be bowling as a few more fights left in them.
I don't think he,
I don't think he necessarily wants to fight for a long time.
I think you're right.
He's undefeated.
He smashes everybody.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think he'll go down as one of the greatest that ever did it.
If he bes George,
Evie beads,
George [inaudible],
George in there.
I mean if he could even get Georgia in there.
I mean who the fuck knows how that,
if that could ever play out.
Yeah.
I mean I want that date with them but we'll,
we'll,
we'll see how that whole thing it also for the UFC,
it wouldn't be for a title,
which is a problem apparently when they,
when they have a problem with like selling paper views.
One of the big problems is,
and this is why,
look everybody else,
why do they have interim tiles?
The reason why they have interim titles because people see that title and they
fucking,
they click that paper view when they might not.
That's real.
It makes it's a big factor in,
it plays into the Yo yo your mindset as a fighter too.
Yes.
And so George would have to come back.
I mean,
someone could do one 65,
they could do one.
So are they going to do one 65?
You know what I mean?
I'm just saying it,
like Dana said,
we would choose to do this doesn't mean that much because Dana is also said that
women would never fight in the UFC.
But Dana said on record,
that won't be a one 65 while he's working there,
we hero.
I hear him.
I don't like that thinking.
I hear him though.
But you know,
I don't get it.
I'm going to why they want to have more weight classes.
Yeah.
I don't get it.
You can make the could be been George fight and it'd be nothing,
uh,
every time.
And George wants to have fight to,
you know,
even just to say hi.
I mean you'll cool motherfucker.
But George even more so.
I tried to pick a fight with them and like,
you know,
for real.
And he called me and we talked for like over an hour and he was like,
he was like,
explain it to me.
He like,
listen,
I listen,
I cannot fight you right now.
I have to get gymnastic.
I can't do the,
uh,
the,
like I said,
I can only do it if I talked to him recently.
If I haven't talked to him recently,
it goes away.
I forget it.
But he told me he was a,
is a great fighter,
but he wanted that I am a better fighter than him and I in,
I feel it,
you know,
this,
I feel that there's risks of a war,
you know what I mean?
Sure.
I'm the type,
I just like taking a big risk,
you know,
more than anything.
Uh,
but George is where you hope you are 10 years from now.
Schorsch is 36 years old.
Sure.
Right?
Is 36 or 37.
He's in,
he's in that range is 36,
37 years old.
You know,
he's,
he did it all.
Get it all.
You know,
he's now,
he's in the position where he's just trying to get them to take five to eight.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
See,
he ain't got much time.
Yeah,
no,
I feel,
and even when he was explaining to me like I was like,
man,
I really can't hate you for this.
Like you,
you kept it like as straight as possible.
He's like,
you know,
it's just too much risks and he's like,
for what?
I like,
I get it Bro.
Make your money.
Look,
I ain't go,
hey.
They called you though.
I,
you know,
I try
to steal and I think he got it too.
He was like,
you know,
I,
I'd get with,
he's a brilliant guy.
I turn on you when you see and talk to him and you're just the way he breaks
down life to waste thinking about life.
He's thinking about it.
Very smart.
That's why when he won the time I was like,
yeah,
I'm good.
I feel like it.
Take it.
Take that title.
I beat Michael Bisping.
I'm going to just ride off into the sunset here for a little bit and hope in a
holding pattern,
waiting for the next big one to come around the next big challenge.
I feel it.
I mean,
there's so much more to life too.
You know what I mean?
It's so big.
Like even even for me,
like I'm dumb.
It's only one part of me,
you know what I mean is the best part.
I think personally I feel like,
but you know,
there's,
this is still so much more that I want to do in a college
fishing and get done.
You know,
the biggest problem with fighters though is that fighting is so crazy and so
wild and spectacular in the highs and the lows,
finding whatever it is.
When you say there's so much more to life,
finding that so much more to life is so difficult for so many fighters.
Yeah,
and I think it's keeping your brain too.
that's,
that's that,
that might
the,
you know,
I don't know.
I ain't nowhere close to that point to start thinking about it.
But I'm like,
but it's hard to know when you're at that point.
Right,
right,
right.
Until it's too late.
Also fighters.
And I like the reason why you think you could beat everybody in the world is the
same thing that's going to get you fucked when you think that you could still go
again.
You know,
I mean that's what got Chuck Odell in trouble when he fought Tito Ortiz.
Most of us that were washing the outside of like,
please don't find him.
Please don't fight anybody.
When Chuck's talking about Fighting Jon Jones like,
oh good lord,
please don't do that.
Cause he's like,
you know,
I think I can get back in there with John Jones.
Like,
Ooh yeah,
like chuck.
But that is why he became chocolate down in the first place.
Cause he's get that unstoppable belief in himself.
But there needs to be balance.
There needs to be balanced.
You can do anything you believe in.
Debt is horse shit.
Anybody tells you to it that you believe in.
That's horse shit.
You know,
there's,
there's certain people that will fuck you up.
You gotta be smart.
Yeah.
Smart.
Yes.
Thank you.
Can still do things that you don't necessarily even know that you can do.
You know,
like I look at it and I'm like,
man,
I never thought that I would truly be like a professional fighter and be able
to,
to live and support my family off this.
So I'm like,
you know,
20 years from now,
how did I look?
I have no idea what it might look like and I have no idea what else I could
possibly do.
You could do anything that,
I firmly,
absolutely believe that.
It's just whether or not you dedicate yourself to it the same way you dedicate
yourself to find it.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I think anybody that can be a professional fighter at the highest level,
that is incredible juggling act of mind and body and discipline and technique
and knowledge and understanding of the past and recognizing traps and,
and,
and intuition.
Knowing when to strike.
No one wanted to back off.
No one to push.
Knowing when to coast it says,
that's a mad fucking race.
I mean,
what you're doing when you're fighting is the most chaotic thing in all of
sport.
And if you could succeed at that at the highest level,
I've really believe you can do anything.
I really believe that.
Yeah.
And I think it takes a lot of,
I think it takes a lot more brain power than,
than,
than people kind of give it credit for it.
And I think that's a big reason why you see guys on the decline to,
you know,
uh,
and I think it's something that not a lot of people look at.
You know,
you kind of see it and you're like,
oh,
this guy's just out of his athletic prime.
Or He's out of,
you know,
he's out of shape or whatever.
But really when you look at them,
you like,
they don't be that much more worn physically.
You know,
maybe certain guys go through like certain injuries and get surgeries and stuff
and it's just not as strong as it was when he was 25.
I get that.
But I feel like fighting in particular,
it's,
it's so much more thinking power and you gotta be quick.
And,
and maybe it's like the damage that they're taken to,
to their actual brain.
Like they aren't processing information the same way.
Not only is it physical,
but it's like it,
it only takes one slip up at the top level for a guy to catch you.
So you know,
if you,
if your brain just that that send up saying working perfectly right,
it's like that's lights out and everybody looks at us like,
oh well he's just out of shape.
He's just getting old and stuff like that.
But it might be something like,
no,
you're taking brain damage in there,
you know?
Yes,
yes.
And I think there's something that happens to fighters when they lose that
belief that they can be the baddest motherfucker in the world.
And that does happen with some fighters.
They get a few losses and then they settle into that journeyman's position.
And you know,
that's what Gustafson just said when he retired.
He said,
I don't want to be a journeyman.
You know,
that journeyman position is a weird position because you know,
you,
you want to get in shape to win,
to beat this guy.
But you kind of know that you'll never be the man.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
like say if you're a guy who's in that 205 pound division and you just keep
losing and then she,
Jon Jones,
who's the greatest of all time,
just fucking everybody up and you know,
you can't beat him.
So your training,
even when you're hitting the bag and running and all that stuff,
you know,
Jon Jones fucked you up twice and you know,
he,
you can't beat him.
You know,
That keeps a lot of guys from having the same enthusiasm and passion that they
had when they were 22 and they thought they could take on the world and they
picture themselves on the cover of fighters only magazine the greatest of all
time.
You know,
everybody has these ideas of who they can be,
but when that idea has been shattered and now you're just a really good fighter,
some fighters just lose their enthusiasm for the game.
And then there's Diego Sanchez who doesn't seem to give a fuck about any of
that.
It just did it
correct people.
You know what,
he's going backwards in time.
Put his clock is toy.
Yeah.
Words.
But I think it's,
he focuses on himself,
you know what I mean?
He don't,
uh,
Eh Diego's out of his mind for sure.
For sure.
But maybe,
maybe he's into his mind,
you know what I mean?
Maybe he's just so like focused on himself and you know,
even if you can't,
you know,
if you look in that John and you're like,
man,
I ain't never gonna catch up to that level.
I'm just not going to beat it then.
Then yeah,
that can really like,
like you said,
like start to,
to really like discourage you a lot.
But then if you're just like,
okay,
I'm better today than I was yesterday and you know,
my,
my jabs like a little,
it's not as straight as it could be,
so let me just work on that and just pick the next thing and just keep
constantly going to that.
I feel like that's what real champions doing on,
they don't necessarily look at,
you know,
the other person and Diego,
even if he ain't got the belt,
he's still in his head like that's maybe high thinking about,
oh no,
you had to talk to him.
He seemed like a crazy dude.
You need to be crazy.
No To do this shit.
You gotta be crazy as all different kinds of crazy,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
when,
when I saw Diego mom,
Micky Gall,
I was like,
God Damn,
look at this guy.
Yeah.
He just has lost no,
no enthusiasms.
Zero,
zero loss and enthusiasm.
After all these years of finding,
you've got to realize that guy won the ultimate fighter season one in 2005 we
are now here.
I was in ninth grade.
14 years later I was in eighth grade,
wasn't even in high school yet.
Jesus,
2005 is crazy.
It's crazy.
He beat Kenny Florian in the finals.
Kenny's long since retired.
You think of all the people he beat long since retired.
I don't know.
It gives it,
it gives you hope a little bit,
you know what I mean?
We like,
no,
when does somebody else has done it so it can be done.
I think he's just,
you know,
into his own head and just like,
it's constantly getting better.
And that's really what the game is about anyway.
Remember when he used to walk to the octagon screaming?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
I would love it.
He's so fucking crazy in the best way.
Yeah.
He's as way he's of his mind.
He's still one of my favorite guys to watch.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
I mean there,
there's a couple of guys like that that kind of keep that,
that same longevity.
So you know,
you gotta look at the past and kind of learn from other people's mistakes and
you know,
see,
Whoa,
okay,
wow.
How was this guy thinking like that?
You know,
when you,
when you look at gloves,
this,
any like he really didn't want to be a journeyman at already lost it.
A two guys holding the title.
So you look at that and you like,
man,
you kind of comparing yourself to,
to them a little bit too much,
you know,
like yeah,
you fought him and the result went what you want it.
But it's like,
okay,
that's just the game.
That's the game.
I think it's also,
he lives in Switzerland or Sweden.
Sorry,
it's fucking beautiful up there.
You'd probably sit in baggies probably Hudson,
you know,
has a tool life and everything.
So you like,
man,
why am I doing this shit for you?
And you know,
I'm about to go back out in front of my whole country if fight another person.
Like come on.
The last time we were,
the first time he fought in front of his whole country was when he got knocked
out by rumble.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ron was the dude where I look back at guys that kind of left the sport and I was
like,
oh,
I get it.
He's been fighting for a long time.
He was wrestling before that.
He didn't want to do it anymore.
I get it.
It will come back.
But this,
I dunno about it now,
man.
But the selfish part of me wanting to see rumble,
get it together and fight for a title.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
not just fight when he fought a DC,
but he'd go had to do it a heavyweight.
Now
it's a bad idea for him to fight it.
Head fucked up.
Our Lawsky and heavyweight,
when he was,
before the Pfl was the Pfl when it was the,
what was it called?
A world series.
The series of flooding.
Yeah.
Dude,
he's murderous.
Striker,
murderous,
you know,
in the heavyweight division is actually a very good division for rumble.
If you really think about it with his speed and power,
first of all,
he hits so fucking hard.
It doesn't matter if someone's a heavyweight,
light heavyweight,
it doesn't matter.
He,
the way he clips people,
it's like Jews.
I mean,
I,
there's a lot of good fights.
I will watch them.
Yeah.
Him if Francis with people,
oh my goodness.
The type of,
uh,
guys like,
like for instance,
another one.
Like he can just find your chin and it's like I've moved around with him a
couple of times and you know,
uh,
you moved around with Francis.
I do some wild shit bro.
Yeah,
I mean he's easy,
gentle wind as far as who was cool school move around with like little kids
sometimes.
He,
yeah,
he's,
he's like a gentle giant,
you know what I mean?
Most guys that you kind of see like that you,
you Kinda,
you kinda realized like,
Oh,
you know your biggest teddy bear.
Yeah,
no.
If you signed up and say I can beat you.
Right.
You see it a different side of them.
But we were just talking to my son,
the oldest do it in the world.
But if he decided to go into pro boxing instead of MMA when he first started
out,
he could be a world champion right now.
Absolutely.
And like I say,
it just moving around with him.
He,
he's got like these weird ways of like this,
the punch just comes it as such an odd angle,
but it's like clean and it's like,
oh damn.
Like,
okay,
I see what you're doing.
You know what I mean?
I think I see what it is.
Uh,
I mean that's the only reason why move around with it.
God like that is to try and see what figured out a little bit.
Yeah.
But there's certain things you just can't teach a person and he's Kinda got
that,
you know,
he's got that,
that killer instinct,
heat sinking missile.
You can't teach that no matter how much you want to hit pads or whatever.
Like sometimes you,
it's in the,
it's in there.
You know,
he's a fascinating story too,
because after he lost a steep pay,
you know,
I think he was absolutely convinced he was going to Knox t pay out and be the
world champion.
He thought he was unbeatable.
Steve Bay just shattered his confidence.
And then he had that crazy fight with Derek where he was just like super
tentative.
Didn't even pull the trigger,
just like,
and in any admitted,
he said,
I carried the fear of my last fight into the cage with me.
And then he came out and starched Curtis blades,
you know,
and then he came out and a starch cane after that.
Like,
okay,
he's back.
Yeah.
I think it took,
it took them some time to kind of uh,
get it back.
Yeah.
To,
to,
to understand what,
what,
what it is and what's going on,
you know,
and to learn from it too,
you know?
Uh,
he,
he's so strong willed and you know,
any,
any like cotton like Kinda got a different culture too,
you know,
coming from Africa in,
in,
in Paris and everything.
So when you talked to him,
I mean,
he's super smart dose,
Super Smart,
but uh,
he's Kinda like me a little bit where it can be hard to get through that,
get through the head,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I mean I,
I admit it and all of those stubborn sometimes and I think he is too a little
bit so it can be hard for lessons to really sink into that.
But I feel like now,
like he,
he's one of those guys where yeah,
you could see it.
It's like coming together for him doing his camps in France.
No.
Uh,
no.
He's been over in Vegas.
One of his camps.
Yes,
he did his last Curtis blades.
Yeah.
You have fun.
I'm not sure where he's doing this next camp or anything.
I don't know.
I was doing a lot of it.
The performance too,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause you're getting good wrestling cause that's really the thing that was
exposed in the,
it comes over to too extreme and you know,
he'll wrestle with us a lot.
You know,
it's,
the problem is just heavy weights,
you know,
it's not a,
a lot of the bigger dudes and he's intimidating too.
So when I,
when I sit back and I'll be watching them move around with certain guys that you
can tell,
like they scared,
you know what I mean?
Oh,
blame.
I don't blame him Bro.
I don't play with either two days.
He scared me when he's on the other side of the cage.
Yeah,
I'm outside the cage and he scares me.
I've wrestled with him a couple times is I really don't really give a fuck,
but he's just so big.
It's hard bro.
It's like I've tried to get it,
you know,
I do my thing.
I try.
I'm a strong guy.
I hold my own,
well it's,
the heavyweight division is very interesting right now because I think a lot of
people are sleeping on Steve pay and I know DC DC clocked him and knocked him
out in that first fight.
But I think Steve [inaudible] is gonna want to come back to the second fight
with a vengeance man.
And I mean he was the most successful heavyweight champion of all time and he
loses the fight,
loses his title,
can't get anyone to pay attention to him all.
I was talking about Brock Lesnar,
DC's going to fight,
but he's like,
Brock Lesnar doesn't even fight.
He's doing fucking WWE.
Like what is this shit?
He goes,
I am the most successful of all time.
I'm the only guy to defend the title four times.
I lose one fight to a fantastic fighter and I can't get a fucking rematch.
Like what is this about?
And then finally there's no one left in the division.
Who else has he got?
He's got to fight him.
Yeah,
I mean that played out perfect for him and I,
and I'm so glad to see it to like Steve Bay is one of the coolest dudes and so
cool in a world bro.
And it's like,
what more do you have to do?
You know what I mean?
Like sometimes I get sick of,
of,
of just the way things are like I don't blame it on the UFC.
I don't blame it on,
on anything.
It's just sometimes that's just the way things are.
It's just the way people are to where like they,
they want to see like you act the food,
they want to see that controversy and they want,
they want to see the negativity all the time.
And it's like,
man,
this is,
it's like a do like Steve Pay.
If Steve Pay can't get no love and he's like a firefighter,
like legitimately saving lives on a daily basis while like training to death and
being a world champion at it.
It's like,
man,
if I do like that,
can't get no love.
I know I stay the chance bro.
But you know,
I'm happy to see these are always going to work out the way it's supposed to
work out.
You know what I mean?
I guess.
But I just felt like the marketing of him could've been so much better.
That was my feeling on it was like,
how do you miss out on this hero?
Yeah.
I mean maybe at a super exciting,
I think it's just American culture maybe.
Cause you see like one fc doesn't necessarily be the same way,
you know?
And they're still doing great.
I mean time will tell how,
how great they really do.
Uh,
but,
but their way of,
of marketing and a guy and promoting them and everything is just so much
different.
It's like,
does that work in America is the problem.
It's like people only want to see what they want to see.
Like even about me,
you know,
like people see me Kinda hit key Essa at the press conference and then that's
all they really know about me.
So that's all they really,
you know,
they think that's me or,
or they,
they,
they even read wrong,
get to that type of situation and they just think that that's how you is.
But she ever talked to Casa after your fight with you guys?
Cool.
He,
I'll go,
he knows.
Oh,
he's pissed because the choke it,
no,
I think he's just met a way.
The whole situation like is awesome.
The choke.
I mean it's almost like,
no,
he would have been better off if he went to sleep.
Yeah.
But he,
he know he,
I mean,
he even said it.
He's like,
yeah,
I mean,
and he's mad that,
that the fight went down the way,
you know,
younger guys and around.
But uh,
but he's more mass still that I hit him.
It's,
the problem was it was so locked in to stop it right there.
Like,
let them go out,
let them tap or go out.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but thing is,
it's,
it's defend yourself,
you know,
but choke,
you don't stop a choke if the guy's awake.
You don't stop a choke.
That's true.
I mean,
there's been a couple of situations where,
where,
you know,
that'll kind of happen in the guy will stop defending himself in the,
in the ref.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll stop it.
And the refs do tell you they like,
they're like,
if you stop defending yourself,
then you know,
what else did they do?
I mean,
yeah,
they could,
you guys just let me choke him out and had been a little easier.
But for us as competitors,
we kind of know,
you know,
I think he just was more upset that it didn't go as well.
Yeah.
That it didn't go his way in and then I hit the button.
But look,
people even read wrong,
get to that into that kind of situation.
Like,
I'm a cool dude.
Like I,
I mean I,
I mean,
I don't mean to say it like that,
but,
um,
I'm always going to give respect to everybody.
You know,
that's just the way I kind of am until you kind of diminish that respect for me
then then you know,
I'm going to give it to you.
So I was talking a little bit,
told him,
you know,
now kind of,
I'm up there,
I'm having fun.
It's my first big press press conference.
Like I'm having fun at it.
But the minute that he got up and ran across the,
towards me,
it's like there's this dividing line almost.
It's like as soon as you step over that UN in my space now it's super fans.
I can't,
yeah.
I can't let,
yeah,
I'm a hit you for it.
That's just the way I,
you know,
you also,
you're in a defensive position.
Like you have to hit them all.
Yeah.
When someone comes at you in the right,
they're like,
oh,
this is a fight.
Yeah.
It's a fight.
I mean,
I,
that's just the way I grew up,
you know,
is any,
anytime,
any spotty,
some,
somebody is gonna you know,
invade your space.
Like you're not going to wait.
Like I'm not going to sit there and see what Paul told the boss could rematch
some time at one 17 one seven.
That's very possible.
A lot of good fights.
Well,
he was another guy that had a real hard time making that way.
He's a big fella.
Yeah.
I mean they hold back on them and for me it's like I've always just wanted a
fair fight,
so,
you know,
uh,
we can weigh in at whatever,
you know,
it's,
it's even with me and dos Anjos I was saying,
you know,
let's weigh in at one 65 and just kind of shut the hand.
He didn't want to do it,
but I'm like,
I just want a fair fight out of the deal.
You know,
it's whatever you want to weigh in.
We shake hands to fight it,
to weigh in at one 65 just to show that this weight class is a viable way class.
I tried to and he wouldn't do it.
Yeah.
He,
he said,
uh,
I don't make a agreements with my opponents.
And I was like,
come on,
you know,
like,
this is our problem in the first place.
That's why I ain't no union or nothing.
You know what I mean?
Like everybody's like against each other.
Like,
come on,
Bro,
we fight in any way.
What do you know what I mean about the idea of a union?
I mean,
I think it's,
I think it's inevitable,
you know?
Yeah.
I think
eventually it's gonna happen.
Um,
how would it happen?
I think it's once a UFC,
the UFC is going to change a little bit.
I feel like it's,
it's just the same way that I'm kind of looking at the way that Facebook has
been doing stuff and,
and,
and all these other,
uh,
companies like these large private companies,
but they're so big and it's,
it's like the UFC is a,
is a sports organization,
you know what I mean?
But it's,
it's so big now to where like,
it's,
I mean,
it's damn near a sport is,
I guess it's damn near public.
You know?
So I think once that kind of changes and people like once they open up the books
and like people really start to pay attention to it,
then maybe somebody on the outside who's way smarter than any one of us or you
know,
cause we're,
we're fighting,
we ain't really worried about the legalities of it.
And,
you know,
I'm just signing a contract.
I don't really give a fuck.
But once somebody who's smarter kind of takes a look at it and see what's going
on in,
in,
in how it is,
then,
uh,
then they're going to start up something.
I mean,
they,
they have to,
I wonder,
it's kind of
crazy.
It would take some sort of crazy lawsuit,
I would imagine.
But I think that fighters are individuals in that then that they,
they think of themselves.
And then if like if you say,
Hey,
I'm going to join the,
yeah,
but that's what I'm saying.
If you say,
Hey,
I'm going to join the union,
you know,
uh,
I'm going to sit out until you guys meet the demands of the union.
And they go,
oh,
that's great,
Colby coven concerns going to take your place.
Now he's going to fight for the title,
and then you're like,
what the fuck?
And then you call Dana,
hey man,
I changed my mind fucked at union.
I'm with you guys.
And that's how it goes.
Yeah.
That,
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah.
But it's kind of a a shame on our part almost.
It's like,
it's the same way is,
is I say,
let's meet at one 65 it's like,
we already don't have a lot of leverage,
bro.
Like,
you know,
yeah.
There's only so many things that we could even do.
I understand those Saundra still.
He's like,
fuck,
we're going to fight anyway.
I don't want to cut that extra five pounds.
You didn't,
I didn't do it either.
I'm like,
Bro,
I'm already,
you've already fought it.
One 70 I'm already taking a loss here.
I'm like,
I'm not gonna give you too many advantages here,
but,
but do you have seed?
They,
you feel like they treat you well?
Yeah.
I mean,
like you obviously you have to be good.
You're in their good graces.
Yeah.
I honestly,
I haven't
no real like complaints about it.
You know,
it's,
I know what I'm,
I'm signing the line,
you know what I mean?
I know what I'm signing up for in a,
in anytime I do and I say I'm going to do something,
I'm always going to make sure I hold up my end and I'm going to do it.
Um,
and it's afforded me so much to,
to where my life is so much different than I thought it would be.
I like,
I truly thought that that everything would just look different,
you know,
and have provided a better life for my family.
Like my mom,
my dad,
and my brother's like,
well,
my one brother at least.
Um,
but,
you know,
it's just afforded me so much that any light negatives on it,
like I can't really,
it's just like
grievances almost.
Yeah.
No,
I understand.
I understand what you're saying.
Have you ever been approached by other organizations,
uh,
before getting into the UFC?
Yeah.
And then,
I mean maybe a little bit here and there,
but you know,
when you see guys like sage Northcutt go over to one FC and Eddie Alvarez and
mighty mouse challenged,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's all good for the sport in general.
You know,
I think even the UFC sees that like competition is always good,
you know,
it's just,
it's just building even more and bigger and better.
Um,
and it's really the sport that we looking after.
So if,
uh,
I mean I'm,
I've been in a contract with UFC for a long while now,
but,
uh,
you know,
if another organization was to ever,
I never know what the future goal,
like what would have ballots are really blows up and not no,
I mean Nah I ain't that names.
The goddamn anchors is true.
Does that mean,
yeah,
kind of a bowling ball,
metal bowling ball around your neck.
Yeah.
Kinda,
I mean,
I don't know.
For me,
I'm getting a UFC is where it's at and,
and 10% you don't want it to be too many organizations either.
You know what I mean?
Cause then you see like Wba
with boxing fight is I get that tear.
That's why,
well that's,
I don't want to be a partner that,
you know,
it's kind of a problem now.
I mean with Douglas Lema Douglas Slim is world class fighter,
but you know,
Rory Macdonald's worldclass fighter,
these guys are world champion Caliber Rory Macdonald could absolutely be a world
champion in the UFC.
Meet BB,
Tyron Woodley.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I think,
uh,
I,
I'm a,
I want to be a part of keeping it all together to,
you know what I mean?
I'm not going to be selfish and be like,
oh well one's going to pay me way more money,
so I'm gonna go over there and do that.
Like I,
I'm a huge fan of the sport in general too.
So I want to see the sport do good and,
and having us all under one roof definitely does help.
Being a UFC champion just fucking means more,
way more.
It just means way more white more.
And I'm gonna do it.
Yeah.
You find out a guy's belt or champion,
like congratulations.
Yeah.
I find that a guy's UFC champion like,
oh shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's different.
Okay.
And,
and,
and I would even want to keep that integrity about it,
you know,
and just filled myself,
you know what I mean?
To,
you know,
just to,
just to know that,
that that's what you did.
You say you're going to do it like that's what you did.
So I think there's a wake up
called know when guys are going over and fighting in these other organizations.
They're realizing now like,
man,
they are world class fighters that you don't know about over in one fc in
particular,
like Timothy nuts.
You can,
the guy that knocked out Eddie Alvarez,
that mother fucker's world class classified as damage where bro.
Yup.
Everywhere.
Treat everybody with the same,
you know,
it's different world.
Yeah.
It's,
it's different.
But it's still like there was a knock you out.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's a different world now.
I'm saying that like you go to these other organizations,
it's not a cakewalk.
Yeah.
They're just as hard and just as dangerous as UFC fighters.
You know when sage fault,
you saw the,
the sage result that cosmo Alexandra guy,
then he followed.
That guy's a beast,
man.
Yeah.
And I'm all for taking big risks.
I really am.
And trying to take the biggest,
hardest fight did you can,
but somebody like that,
it was like,
somebody should've probably gotten to say Jared was like,
Hey,
listen,
like
this dude's a legit world champion.
Kickboxer you know,
I had just fought Nikki Hoschi,
you know,
that's a huge level of,
of uh,
experience that you're talking about coming from fighting somebody like Zack
Ottawa to,
you know,
he's like,
that's a huge jump,
you know?
And it's the Grand Canyon with a scooter.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
It's just sometimes the biggest risks ain't necessarily the smartest either.
You know,
you can legit get hurt in a sport.
Like it's,
it's a sport,
but it's real life too.
Like you,
you can legit get hurt,
you can lose your life.
So yes.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
And also particularly cause sages Nano Pressler yeah.
You know,
so he's going to stand,
stand up with this dude with four ounce gloves on.
And he had never fought in a ring before,
at least I don't think,
I mean,
I don't know.
But when you watch
that fight and you see the way he was moving,
it's like he didn't expect that punch to come.
You didn't expect him to be able to cut them off like that.
When you look at a ring,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's 180 degrees right there.
So you only have one way to move.
Never moved that way.
You know?
That's a really good point actually.
I didn't even consider that.
Whoever has,
you know,
his coaches should have been like,
listen,
like we need to work our way up there.
You know what I mean?
Or,
or,
uh,
I think they might've had a false misconception of going over to one and one,
treating him real good and they're going to give you a good fight.
So,
you know,
they don't want to build you.
I think one is signing guys to be like,
we got some of the git talent over here.
We going to sign you.
You go make your money.
But,
uh,
you have to earn that money.
They can mean a solid,
they threw him right to the top champions either.
It's like they threw him to a world class fighter than they look.
They've got world class talent.
They really do.
And so does Bellah tour now,
you know,
I feel like Douglas Lema is as good as any hundred and 70 pounder in the world
and just knocked out by Michael Van and page like,
Holy Shit.
Brutal too.
Gay Garden was saucy is absolutely one of the best hundred and 85 pounders in
the world yet.
You know what I mean?
He's as world classes they get.
Yeah.
And there's so much talent.
Like you do need to keep it all under one umbrella though.
I think,
you know,
Ben's a fan of the sport is,
and it's better for us fighters too.
You know,
like I,
I'm a competitor,
so I want to compete against the best of the best.
I don't want it like a bunch of,
you know,
like where's boxing where,
you can't make two fights happen and because of this promoter doesn't work with
this promoter and,
and you've got to go through three,
four years of,
and the whole time a guy like Joshua was kind of sitting back and like,
man,
I don't know.
I,
I don't get to fight these guys so I really don't know how good I am or,
or something.
Uh,
where to stay.
You just like,
let's just go out there and compete and the later chips out and wherever they
fall is,
where are they gonna fall?
You only get to be able to do that if everything's under one roof.
Yeah.
I'm really enthusiastic and hopeful about this ESPN deal too,
cause I think that's going to expose a lot more people to the sport because
there's so many people that are just casual sports fans that always have the TV
on ESPN.
I mean that is America's network for sports.
And they're good too.
They're good.
Like working with them for this last,
uh,
a fight and you're getting ready to do the build up and everything.
It just seeing the way that they do certain things,
there's like,
there's no fat on it,
you know,
there's no,
like,
there's no lag.
There's no delays.
There's no,
you know,
uh,
it just,
everybody's just on,
on top of their game.
Like they're real professionals.
That is so beautiful.
Yeah.
I think it's love hearing that.
I think it's going to be big put.
I've been very impressed with their promotion to the way they promote things,
where they put things together.
Even the way the handle social media,
it's a notch up and you could tell like that they,
they're just have so much experience in sports.
I mean there forever.
Right.
I mean they're the leaders forever.
Beautiful.
I think,
uh,
you know,
social media is going to probably be the last little little leg up that cause
our sport is living in died on it almost.
Yeah.
Uh,
and that's going to be like I met shying away from it.
Like I don't really fuck with it like that no more.
Just cause I don't think it's right.
You know what I mean?
I think eventually it's going to change and it's going to get to be way better.
And then once that happens,
like then the sport really like,
wait,
what do you mean?
Like in what way?
What do you,
what don't you think is right about it?
I just don't know.
You know,
I haven't been getting on it lately just because for me it was like I started
noticing that it was changing my outlook on things.
Like it was like I was almost doing stuff for the purpose of putting it on
social media or I wasn't like enjoying my life as much.
I was more so worried about like how it was going to look or you know,
what it,
how acting use this.
And I was always kind of suddenly like scheming and plotting.
Uh,
and it's just,
I didn't think it was healthy.
And I,
and then I started to see the effect that it was having on other people too.
And in,
or just people around me in general.
He's like,
I was noticing it was terrible for my little brother.
And I think it's terrible for the kids in general.
And it just made it to where everything was.
So you only got to see little glimpses of things.
You know what I mean?
People take the perfect picture and a perfectly of course and all this.
So that's just what you see.
And you only got to see the,
the,
the shine and the glitz and the glamor and stuff.
So when it,
when a young kid is looking at that,
he's like,
and he's going to see thousands of likes on it too,
you know?
And that's what everybody likes a,
so it,
it just almost makes you feel like,
man,
that's what I should be.
You know what I mean?
And,
and when you not that,
then they can give you such a,
a dangerous outlook on yourself to where you'll do some stupid to,
to beat it almost to where I feel like it's going to change.
It's going to be different.
How so what do you think's going to happen?
A couple of weeks ago,
I saw that they were talking about,
uh,
you know,
taken away the likes.
You are going to see it.
People will jump off buildings.
I would love that though.
I would get back on it.
I'd be on Instagram full fledged they said they were thinking about taking away
the number of followers too.
So you couldn't see.
Yeah.
How many followers of the people have,
I don't see why not.
I don't see why you need to see it or I don't see why,
you know,
I guess I didn't know how ridiculous it is when,
when,
uh,
when like sometimes,
like I'll,
I'll see someone like with,
with kills me as why I'm looking like the search area and there's some girl
doing squats and a thong and I was like,
let me see how many followers she has.
18 million.
Yeah.
But,
but my thing is what good does that,
do you know what I mean?
I'm happy
because it's so crazy.
But even even,
you know,
it's huge and fighting and stuff,
but you know,
I look on it and like certain people have like millions of followers in this
that,
but does that necessarily translate to
anything tangible?
You know what I mean?
Anything real.
It's like,
I don't necessarily know.
I don't know what the,
I don't know if anybody's done any studies and like really looked at that to see
a po.
I don't necessarily think it does and I don't really think it matters.
I think the only thing it does is like play into your own head where you like,
you know,
oh he's getting so many lights or you post something,
you're like,
aw man,
I get this many likes and stuff.
But it's like it does,
it doesn't matter.
You know?
I guess for the,
the only way I could see it mattering is for the algorithms.
You know,
people like to see what other people like,
so that makes sense.
But we don't necessarily have to see that.
You know what I mean?
If,
if like where Bray rod is doing his videos,
love them,
I'm going to look at them whether they got a hundred likes or they got a 100,000
you know,
I'm going to follow him whether he's got a million followers or 100 followers.
You know what I mean?
I think that's probably the way it should be more because that seems more like
real life.
Yeah,
I get what you're saying.
Um,
but in this day and age,
everybody wants to,
they want to know,
oh this is the number one show on.
Like Netflix is an interesting thing because you never know what the fuck
Netflix ratings are.
You have no idea if you watch like say Ozark or something like that.
No one has any idea other than Netflix.
Netflix knows they don't tell you shit.
Like when I do comedy specials on Netflix,
they go,
we love it.
Thank you.
But here's the thing,
it does stop me from watching it.
That's true.
If anything it makes it a little better.
You know what I mean?
Like I think so at least cause cause now you got your own little thing that you,
that you kind of getting into.
I don't really like following the crowd that much.
Maybe that's what the way I'm thinking about it.
But you know,
it don't stop me from watching it.
I wonder if the actually do that.
I wonder if they do do that.
If engagement will go down.
I'm sure Netflix,
you know when you look at Netflix is model.
Uh,
I'm pretty sure that algorithm is,
is showing like okay this is getting this many lights.
Let's put this on the front page.
So more people are going to click on it.
That makes sense.
I mean you don't necessarily have to see how many people watch it.
Yeah.
Um,
well Netflix does it also for negotiation purposes.
Sure.
Like say when I do a special,
like I know my last special got more views than my first special,
but I don't know how many you got.
They don't tell you shit.
He didn't say we were very happy.
We're very,
very happy.
Well tell me how many people watching.
We can't tell you that.
You can't tell me they're laughing.
We're very happy,
very happy with the fuck.
Does that mean tell me how many people,
oh,
well if it makes you feel better,
you'll see us doing that now.
ESPN,
you don't know how many
pay per view is that?
It's getting it's of man is less the promise.
Not many.
The first one they did was less than a hundred thousand yeah,
that's not good when you consider that,
you know,
that was a chai fight.
You know Max Holloway,
Dustin Poirier a big ass fucking fight.
100,000 not even a hundred thousand pies.
But that takes away from our,
our,
uh,
value as fighters.
You know what I mean?
Cause you know what I'm saying?
You don't truly get to see it.
That's also because it's streaming,
because this transition to ESPN plus,
and it's going to take a while before everybody
realizes 100% this is the only way you're going to get the paper view.
The only way you're gonna watch the fights.
You got to get the APP.
Yeah,
that's a great app.
It's going to take a lot all the time.
I have it on.
I have apple TV at home,
so I watch it on that.
Seamless.
I like it.
Yeah.
I mean me too.
But then again,
I'm a just,
I'm a follow on wherever they go.
But the zone is the same way too.
Like I watched the Joshua,
I'm Ruiz fight.
I watched that on disown.
That's fucking excellence.
The same thing.
Yeah.
I mean in the numbers from,
from stuff like that,
it's like,
that's what I mean.
I think eventually is going to change the way we really got to see the true
numbers.
It's going to have to,
because I wonder,
because when you,
when you see like Canelo Alvarez make a 25 million or wherever he did in his
last fight,
and then you hear he's only got,
you know,
800,000 subscribers that signed up for does own.
But then you look at at,
uh,
800,000 subscribers on design.
That's what I heard.
At least that he says.
True Google.
How many subscribers does design have Daaz n I was calling it Dayson forever.
And there was no,
no,
no man.
It's like,
well you need a fucking oh and an e.
But then you look,
I mean,
I don't know,
Jamie would probably pull up the number.
But then when you,
when you look at like all the same night owl fought cowboy,
which is a way better fight Tuesday amazings fight,
great fight.
But you know,
ESPN,
I don't know how many numbers,
you know,
they don't say the numbers of my subscribers,
but it's gotta be comparable.
But that was a free fight.
He didn't have to see.
The thing is about ESPN plus you get free fights and then you get paper views.
So the cowboy versus ally quantified was a great fight,
but it was free.
So if you've got that APP,
you just watched the fight.
But I think the zone is same way.
You don't,
you don't have to buy them.
You just pay per month.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But the UFC for paper view is not,
so when you get a pay per view fight,
you have to pay.
So that's a little weird,
right?
Like maybe make it a little more money,
make it 10 bucks a month and give everybody everything.
That'd be crazy.
What did WWE did?
Yeah,
and it was a huge success.
They'll probably figured that out.
It took a while.
It was a,
it was rocky [inaudible] modeled as old 4 million,
4 million subscribers to design.
That makes sense.
That's really,
if they had from their vice president of North America said that in my TV show.
But yeah,
I don't know that whale worldwide subscribers in North America subscribers.
I don't,
that doesn't matter.
It's internet doesn't matter,
but it's a 4 million people suddenly be,
you are right in this guy's full of shit and no,
no,
I think that's totally right.
I think I,
yeah,
that's totally right.
But it limits your ability to negotiate,
right?
Because you don't know like with Directv,
like,
hey,
directv says there's 700,000 pay per view,
buys,
know,
big hit.
Everybody's happy.
You get a piece of that like,
Oh boy,
we've got this much money coming in.
Like what?
How are they doing deals now for paper?
You,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I ain't going to read negotiation yet,
but you know,
do they,
after your fight,
do they give you a window of time before you,
they contact you and hit you up with another fight?
Like how does that work knowing me,
I wanted to get back in there and August.
Uh,
but you know what's up Jeremy?
I'm not reading that at,
they were publicly saying that,
uh,
one point more than 1.2 million people watched worldwide,
Canelo's last fight.
So it's not that,
that's the way that's way less.
Well that's not that many because it's free,
right?
Once you have the zone that's free,
which is interesting that the UFC has a different model than that.
Only thing I mean is Canelo gets 25 million and then,
uh,
you know,
Allah cowboy get about a hundred grand a piece.
So there's like,
you know,
where's the value in is going on and then it's not only the Canelo I think like
three fights a down,
you know,
on the,
on the cart.
Like that guy got like a hundred grand,
I don't even know his name.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
we look at the purse out Canelo God,
I like a $600 million.
Stupid,
insane,
right?
I didn't,
they just signed Tyson fury did something similar like that with ESPN.
He got us some crazy similar deal as well.
And Anthony Joshua was with the zone to another crazy deal.
It's all weird right now,
right?
Everybody's trying to figure out what the future is and they're banking on
streaming,
which I think is the correct bet.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's changing.
Everything is,
unless everything I think is gonna gonna Change,
it's just,
it's just taken a little bit of time before it all,
we used to prompt around right at a cowboy and I lie Quinta.
We surprised that result.
No,
no,
not really.
The way,
uh,
I was surprised at what that long,
you know what I mean?
I,
I thought,
uh,
the only way cowboy are,
the only way Al was going to win is if he would have knocked them out,
uh,
early,
um,
is just the kicks would have been too much.
And it was like,
I think that first left switch kick that he through and kind of caught out on
top of the head a little bit.
Uh,
I think that,
yeah,
that was,
yeah.
I wasn't necessarily surprised.
Hey,
cowboy has been on his game for sure.
It's been on [inaudible] which brings up this weekend.
Tony Ferguson cowboys.
Yeah.
Own Holy Shit.
Fight.
Ooh,
I'm so excited about that fight.
I see it going to tonitto really have to,
you know,
I,
at first I didn't,
I thought that cowboys just,
just to,
to on his point,
um,
cobbles timing might be a little bit better.
So you know,
and Tony does get hit so that's something to look at.
But I think Tony's just unorthodox movements and in the way he throws punches
and moves his head at the same time as throwing punches cowboy,
he likes to kind of leave his head up there and maybe get hit to the body or
something.
So Tony's relentless,
relentless.
Yeah.
That mother fucker never gets tired and he keeps it somebody robbed her.
Yes,
yes.
It's a three round it cause it's the third fight below the main event.
So the main event is so Hutto Marla Mris,
which is another fucking phenomenal fight.
Yeah.
Mother's got a lot of power.
Oh,
he's got everything.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
35 or two.
That dude's jacked.
That's a big,
uh,
that's a,
that's like a big risk going up for pseudo,
I think.
You know,
and you know,
he's such a champ though.
He'd been at,
at the top of multiple sports for so long that he's got so much experience.
He,
he's gonna know how to handle it.
Right.
But it's a good fight.
It's better than that.
People are given credit for it for sure.
Yeah.
He just wants to be champ champ.
You know,
as long as the two champ champs,
he wants to number three.
Well,
there's,
hey champ.
Champs.
I'm sorry because a,
I'm a,
can we call this something else?
Uh,
Amanda Newman.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Can we call it something else from you?
We'll be going to like it because it's too many of them now.
It's like,
okay kid,
I liked her.
You call a chance.
Yeah,
I'm a DC became champ champ.
I got excited.
But then when you
defend the belt,
you know for two or three times,
are you,
are you champ champ,
Dan?
You know what I mean?
You won the title twice and definitive.
It should be champ champion,
but when you win two divisions,
you are champ champ.
You stop fucking around Kevin Lee.
I'm,
hey.
Hey,
you can't take away a Mandy Nunez is champ champ.
If she decides to never fight at featherweight again,
she is champ champ.
Period.
I,
yeah,
you're right.
Straight up murderer.
You are right.
But you know,
I wish we call it something different.
He just mad that Connor invented.
Yeah.
I ain't gonna lie.
That's about Jamie.
Do you know rumbles not fighting,
but he's soon too.
That's a dangerous fight.
If you want to keep your knees like Greg Jones is no God damn joke.
Craig Jones is a heal hook and mother fucker.
He is.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Craig Jones is at the top of the food chain in the submission grappling world,
but he's not as big as rumble,
but I don't think anybody's drug testing.
But that means I'm not drug testing rumble.
So who knows?
I don't even know if they have to weigh in.
I don't think they're going to weigh in.
They're calling it like a David versus Goliath maps.
So I don't blow wait.
Oh rose gold stolen 350 pounds.
I wonder what rumbles going away because Craig Jones has been grappling.
I want,
I want to say he's probably around two 15 to 20 long guys.
Not,
not incredibly ripped,
but this submission grappling world is very strange because there's no real drug
testing to speak of and everybody kind of knows that everybody's kind of juiced
up.
You know that for Brazil,
Brazil Jones is from Australia.
But I've just made that some of those guys,
you know what I mean?
But,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't think it comes to that much into play in grappling with so much
technique and leverage a ball,
it comes into play.
It helps you train much longer,
much harder,
stronger,
especially with no g probably does,
you know,
I think in Nogi well I think it works with key too.
It's just,
look,
it's physical.
It's a physical thing.
You get two guys,
one guy's on juice,
one guy doesn't,
the guy who's on juice has some sort of an advantage if they're both technically
similar.
But that's a tough fight for rumble in that Craig is used to being on the bottom
and he's used to fighting with,
with inside control of the legs.
Like,
I don't know what kind of rumble,
what kind of leg lock game rumble has.
Is this Dennis Hallman.
Chuck Doris.
Oh yeah.
And the crazy thing is,
um,
Dennis Hallman went for a fucking heel hook here and Craig Jones was like,
nope,
not a good idea.
Yeah.
Fuck you fucked his leg.
Good idea.
Yeah.
I feel like that's going to be the next little evolution that you're seeing.
MMA.
It's like lox.
Lox.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I've really started to incorporate it a little bit into,
into my game.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
especially against wrestlers.
Like I'd be a little worried if I was uh,
uh,
in rebels corner for that cause wrestles a little more susceptible to,
to leg locks for sure.
So I feel like that's going to be like the next little level that you see guys.
You have to understand the system and I don't,
I'm not a leg lock guy.
It's hard.
Yeah,
I see the transitions but if I was on the mat with them I wouldn't be a step
ahead.
I wouldn't be able to like know where they're going and I would have to react as
it's happening,
which is a giant disadvantage and I don't know what rumble knows.
I know he was a great wrestler and brumble his big thing was never submitting
people so fucking people up standing up.
Yeah.
I mean I think the best way is just to try and disengage from them and just not
let him have your legs.
It's just,
that's easier said than done.
I look with all that with Craig Jones.
It's just the thing with those guys is when you're rolling with someone who is
that high level with submissions,
you are reacting and they know how you're gonna react and they're anticipating
your reaction and they have a counter to your reaction and you're always one
step behind so you can explode and explode,
explode and eventually you get a little tired and then who hoop and know
Hickson.
He's talk about that.
It's like they can keep the rhythm.
That's what I always say.
They can't keep the rhythm like this cause it just keep going.
They keep attacking and you just can explode and explode and show everybody how
athletic you are.
But after awhile that shit wears out and then next thing you know you're wrapped
up in something.
Yeah.
And I think they see more guys like you.
You know what I mean?
They seem more guys that are just trying to,
you know,
they see a lot of wrestlers and all that guys.
Just try those same kinds of defenses.
Were you not seeing that many guys that are good at let locks like that?
Especially to the point where now they're starting to understand it way more
technically than,
you know,
like [inaudible] style of just grab your foot and just trying to like squeeze
the shit off cars.
Had some good technique.
But if [inaudible] complex is like a,
you know,
Eddie Cummings or something.
Yeah.
I don't mean by Harvard said General,
I just mean that style of doing it.
You know,
some guys you just see like they just grab your foot and just twist it the way
it ain't supposed to go.
But you know,
when you look at a guy like a Donna here style,
uh,
and he's breaking it down like a mad scientist.
He's like,
you know,
there's literally going to be no way that you're going to get out of those
different levels of it.
You know,
you've seen that with Gary tone in now and I remember,
yeah.
Yeah.
Gary tone was fighting over in one.
He just submitted the shit out of somebody with an inside.
He'll hook.
Has he fought against it?
We just fought real recently.
Just fall like a week ago.
Oh Wow.
He's going to be a world champion.
I really believe that.
Yeah.
I've seen his,
uh,
his,
his first like to maybe,
well he's undefeated.
He's foreign.
Oh,
now.
okay.
And,
uh,
it's just the way he's winning too.
He's,
he's fucking people up and he's super dedicated and he's just real smart.
And when he's got with a guy like Donna her in his corner,
like Donna her is another guy and he's also,
by the way,
you know,
he's locked up for asa hobby.
They're all like in cahoots together.
They trained together,
but Donna has got a special brain.
He really does.
He has a special understanding of submissions.
Yeah.
I want to talk to that guy.
Shut him out.
Yeah,
definitely should go get on down in New York.
Yeah.
He's the type of visit to him.
He's the type of dude I said that I talked six hours what it was like.
He goes,
he seems like he's got that,
you know,
systematic way of,
of breaking stuff down.
So I kind of liked that,
uh,
because it takes the guesswork out of it.
You know what I mean?
It takes the,
what if he does this?
Oh,
well then he has got an answer for it.
Would it be,
does this,
he's got an answer.
But you know,
uh,
that's why I feel like I'm kind of missing him.
Like whoa necessarily that my game.
But yeah,
I think that would be a great addition to anybody's games to train down there
and understand what that guy's doing or,
I mean there's a,
there's quite a few different systems now and then you got like Craig Jones
who's coming,
like I said from Australia,
he's got,
he's got a very similar system to,
it's just,
everybody's got different approaches to it.
But what Donna her did and that Henzel Gracie team did is they just kind of like
proof of concept.
Just let everybody know,
hey,
like you're missing out on,
on a giant chunk of this thing.
And a giant chunk of this thing is all the variables that come into play when
guys are trying to rip each other's knees apart.
Yeah,
yeah.
It kind of goes back to even like,
you know,
those individual sports are so ahead of,
of,
of ours,
you know,
like what we were talking about earlier,
when you seeing worldclass Jujitsu fighters are a worldclass Moyie Thai fighter.
It's,
they're just better at that thing then the guys who do everything.
Yeah.
So I mean a couple of years ago you saw more like Jujitsu gold,
tobacco tax and you know,
uh,
arm bars were like really big in it.
Um,
and now you,
then they kind of went through like the leg lock era and I feel like we kind of
stuck on the back of tech kind of our bar and eventually we'll move over to,
to,
uh,
being able to pull up leg locks.
Cause now you see it,
a lot of Jujitsu guys kind of get away from the leg lock and starting to under
the defense is starting to catch up a little bit.
Um,
I didn't get to go to worlds to,
to see it,
but you know,
um,
I always like to stay one step ahead of it and see where it's going.
You know what's on the other side of it.
It's interesting.
In a world they were weighing the
fighters before they got onto the mat.
That's how you weighed in.
Yeah.
You have to make weight with your Guianan at the side of the mat and then you
drink some water and then go roll.
So they're trying to discourage any and all way cutting
that works if you're not getting hit,
you know what I mean?
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
When you talk about like punching each other,
some gods are still going to cut weight and that's too big of a risk to take
care of me.
Yeah.
You dangerous.
Very,
very dangerous yet very dangerous brain is,
you know,
and,
and this was even an idea that I had kind of head was like,
I wonder why nobody creates some type of fluid field,
uh,
heck here of some sort.
You know what I mean?
Like when you think about like your brain,
your brain is surrounded by that,
the,
that fluid.
And that's really what's protecting it,
you know,
more so than even like the thickness of your skull or anything.
So when you put in,
you know,
I,
I get why they like boxing.
Amateur boxing is starting to take away the head gear because they are saying
it's making it more dangerous.
It's really only helping the guy who's punching you.
Right.
You know,
when you punch somebody with a headgear you can go play full blast.
So it's also their head snaps more because there's weight on the neck.
Yeah,
it's,
it's actually making it worse,
you know?
Uh,
where if you had something that was fluid,
feel kind of recreating the inside of you,
hit then that would absorb and shake the water.
You know,
like almost like those,
uh,
those water bags,
you know,
when you hit those,
like you can feel like it's a little,
it absorbs the,
the,
uh,
impact a little bit different.
I just wonder,
I mean,
I don't,
it probably not a good idea.
Like maybe if you busted and he got water flicking flowing everywhere or
something,
but that's what
deal.
But I think you're right.
That makes sense.
If they could design it correctly and figure out a way to disburse the impact
better.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Yeah.
F Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know that they,
they should just do some serious testing.
No,
now I don't know why.
And uh,
I'm part of the Cleveland Clinic.
I'm over in,
in,
in Vegas.
They,
they've got this study going on for a couple of years where they take you in and
they,
uh,
they run you through an Mri scan and they do all these different types of tests
on you on a lot on the computer,
like testing your reaction skills,
testing and balance testing all the,
you know,
different parts of your brain.
Um,
it's been a couple of years now.
I think I've been part of them for like four years.
I go in twice a year to,
to get it done.
But that just seems like it's gonna take so long before you really notice
anything.
And when you do that,
do they tell you your results based on how you were six months ago?
Yeah,
they,
they give me,
I actually just asked for the Mri scans because they tell you and it just like,
yeah,
no,
you're fine.
Like,
you know,
like Yo results are the,
cause it's Kinda in the same test that you're taking over and over and over
again.
So they just kind of match them up to how you did last time.
And you know,
if you scored a 98 on the last one,
you scored 90 on this one.
It's like,
okay,
that's cool.
You know?
Yeah,
you've,
you fine.
But to me,
I asked him for the actual Mri Scans.
I don't know how to read an Mri like that.
Right.
But you know,
cause I want to see like the,
even though it's got to be deeper than that,
it's got to be deeper than two plus two and you know,
all this shit,
like it's gotta be something more to it.
Like they should just do a study where they take up holistic kit and hit it a
bunch of times and see what's happening to the brain of it.
You know what I mean?
Right,
right.
Left Francis Poncha.
Yeah.
Like,
I want to know,
you know,
I think,
uh,
and I think fans are like want to know,
like,
you don't want to give you your brain to this shit.
Right.
You know,
and it's like,
and then you could do stuff where you put some over it,
put a headgear on it,
see if it makes it worse.
But like I said,
water head.
Do you think you're ever going to get to a point where they'll have a study that
they can like a test like that they could do another fighter and they'll say,
hey man,
you can't fight anymore.
Yeah,
for sure.
Cause they really don't have that right now,
which is why they let chocolate,
Dell fight Tito Ortiz.
Right?
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
just like Mr,
like an MRI,
you know,
like a couple of years ago,
you wouldn't be able to get the same type of images.
Um,
and now when you see like some of the stuff that they're really coming out with
medically,
um,
I think that's going to advance so much more to where you're gonna really be
able to see like the individual neurons in,
in,
in self identity.
You guys see like,
okay,
you're breaking up these d these parts of your brain that we couldn't see
before.
You know,
you can see what an x ray,
you couldn't see it with a what,
an MRI.
A lot of times they can't see until the autopsy.
Right?
Right.
So hopefully as,
as technology improves and as we get better on that front,
like,
then we can just start to take some of that,
uh,
is that technology in and use it for what we doing,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
Kevin Lee has been a blast.
Let's do it again.
Six months.
Let me know what a year.
A year.
We'll be here a year.
We'll beautiful.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate you,
man.
Kevin Lee,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.